[Musique]
Gill Ravo, bonsoir.
Bonsoir.
Comment allez-vous ?
Ben écoutez, ça va. Toutes mes excuses
pour le retard, j'étais je suis venu en
vélo, c'est pour ça m'a mis plus de
temps que prévu. Donc
est-ce que vous pouvez m'excuser auprès
des téléspectateurs.
Est-ce que vous pouvez vous présenter
succintement ? Et ben succintement, je
dirais que je suis un prof
et je fais d'autres trucs mais euh je
suis surtout et avant tout un prof et ma
fille me le reproche assez souvent parce
que je suis un prof avec tout le monde
tout le temps. Et en fait, j'aime bien
ça, c'est-à-dire apprendre plein de
trucs, travailler comme un taré et après
en très peu de temps dire aux autres ce
que j'ai appris et discuter avec eux
pour voir ce qu'ils en pensent.
Donc vous êtes prof de quoi ?
Je suis prof d'économie, pardon.
Et vous êtes maître de conférence ?
Voilà, je suis maître de conférence.
Alors, c'est marrant parce que maître de
conférence, c'est un titre assez
ronflant et en fait maître de
conférence, c'est le grade inférieur
quand vous êtes universitaire. C'est que
c'était les c'est les petits. Les
grands, c'est ce qu'on appelle les
professeurs d'université. Moi, je suis
petit, je vais le rester sans doute
toute ma vie et j'enseigne des
universités très pauvres, misérables, la
LED, qui s'appelle l'université Paris 8,
qui évidemment n'est pas à Paris mais à
Saint-Denis en scène en scène
Saint-Denis.
Aujourd'hui, on a décidé de vous faire
venir pour parler de votre appréciation,
votre vision de l'économie et votre
prospective concernant notre économie en
terme de société française. On va
commencer par de la macro, de la micro.
Vous voulez commencer par quoi ?
Macroéconomie, microéconomie ?
Macroéconomie, c'est pas mal, non ?
Alors, je pense que la macroéconomie en
fait, c'est un terme barbare qui désigne
quelque chose de très simple. C'est ce
qui occupe l'actualité, la presse. Donc,
qu'est-ce que c'est que la macroéconomie
? tout simplement lorsqu'on parle ben de
crise, lorsqu'on parle de déficit, quand
on parle de croissance, d'inflation, de
chômage, d'inégalité, c'est la
macroéconomie et moi effectivement c'est
c'est plutôt mon domaine de spécialité.
Ouais.
Donc aujourd'hui, on est en train de de
traverser une crise sans pareil depuis
les 100 dernières années.
Euh on a un président de la République
qui fait peu normal ce qu'il peut ou
erreurs qui qu'il ne refuse d'assumer.
Et qu'est-ce que vous pouvez nous dire
des perspectives pour l'économie
française en terme d'échiquier
géopolitique mondial et en terme de
microéconomie les perspectives pour nos
entreprises plus locales ?
Voilà. Moi ce que je dirais aux gens,
c'est que s'ils ont envie de passer une
bonne soirée, il faut qu'ils fassent
autre chose que m'écouter. Euh
moi ce que j'ai envie de dire, c'est ce
que je dis partout où je passe, pardon,
c'est que c'est que je vais très mal et
que je pense qu'on est très nombreux à
aller très mal pour de bonnes raisons et
que je pense que c'est important qu'on
se le dise et qu'on le dise. C'estàd que
je pense qu'il y a un gros problème à
avoir dans les grands médias. Je
consomme énormément de médias comme
comme pas mal de gens surtout en ce
moment. À la télé, à la radio, on a des
gens qui vont bien, on a des gens qui
sont pas affectés par le confinement
parce que eux, ils se baladent
normalement, ils sont justement au
travail. Une mesure très simple
aujourd'hui qui changerait toute la
discussion nationale, c'est si les
ministres, si les journalistes, même si
moi là actuellement, on se forçait à
respecter le confinement. C'est-à-dire
que si tous ces gens-là étaient chez eux
à 18h ou à 19h et donc il y aurait pas
le journal de 20h, s'ils subissaient
dans leur vie très privilégiée
simplement cette contrainte, je suis
certain qu'il y aurait beaucoup plus de
soignants à l'hôpital. Ces gens-là, la
crise, ils ne la voient absolument pas,
sauf si par malheur ils chopent eux
personnellement le virus. Et cette
explication très basique, en fait, elle
explique beaucoup de problèmes de notre
société. le fait par exemple qu'à
l'Assemblée nationale, on a une majorité
qui n'a jamais été aussi éloignée de la
société française d'un point de vue
sociologique. C'estàd que les députés
ont toujours été plus éduqués que la
moyenne, plus riche que la moyenne. Mais
là maintenant, notamment dans le le
groupe parlementaire de la République en
marche, expression très bizarre
d'ailleurs quand on y pense, on a des
gens qui ont toujours vécu dans
l'opulence, qui sont très
majoritairement issus de milieux très
favorisés et qui simplement ne
connaissent pas à un point dont ils ne
se rendent absolument pas compte
eux-mêmes la réalité du pays.
Là, j'enchaîne tout de suite avec une
question internet qui question avoqué du
diable. En quoi un professeur connaît-il
la réalité du terrain économique ? Hm
ben moi, je sais que je la connais pas
justement et je pense que c'est ma
chance. C'est ce que je dis tout le
temps à mes élèves. Euh il se trouve que
la formation en économie est devenu très
très mauvaise dans tous les pays du
monde depuis des décennies. C'est un de
mes combats hein de quand j'étais quand
j'étais jeune en en 2000, on avait lancé
avec d'autres un mouvement de critique
de l'enseignement de l'économie. Moi,
j'étais déjà plus vraiment un étudiant,
j'étais au début de ma thèse et on
critiquait exactement l'irréalisme des
modèles économiques. On critiquait ce
qu'on avait appelé d'un terme très
malheureux, mais malheureusement très
parlant, l'autisme de la science
économique et des professeurs de fac en
économie. Ce site existe toujours, il
s'appelle autisme économie. À l'époque,
il se trouve que ce mouvement-là avait
eu un retentissement national et même
mondial. Il y avait Jack Lang. Jack
Langue qui était ministre de l'éducation
et il avait commandé à Jean-Paul Fitoi
qui était sans doute l'économiste, je
dirais le meilleur économiste de France
à l'époque.
On l' su ici
voilà qui est quelqu'un de passionnant
et qui a écrit un très beau rapport sur
l'enseignement de l'économie qui
évidemment n'a été suivi d'absolument
aucun effet. Et dans son rapport
Jean-Paul Fitoui nous dit ceci. Il nous
dit sur le modèle des meilleures
facamment des facérines. Il nous dit
pendant les premières années d'étude à
la fac il faut que ce soit
pluridisciplinaire. C'est qui dit
pendant les 3 années de licence si vous
faites de l'économie répond tout à fait
à la question qui vient d'être posée,
vous devez faire aussi de la sociologie,
de l'histoire, du droit, voire même des
maths, ce que vous voulez. Il faut que
vous ayez un enseignement
pluridisciplinaire pour vous confronter
à d'autres approches, à d'autres façons
de penser et à d'autres manières
d'appréhender la réalité. Et moi, ce que
j'ai vécu comme étudiant et ce que j'ai
vécu malheureusement ensuite comme
enseignant, puisque ce combat là, comme
tous les combats que j'ai mené depuis 20
ans, on les a totalement perdus.
Aujourd'hui, dans ma fac d'économie,
vous nous réunissez là tous les
collègues de la fac, vous nous mettez
une carte de France et vous nous dites
qu'est-ce qu'on produit en France ?
Personne ne sait. Vous nous demandez des
grandeurs sur la dette publique, sur le
chômage. Moi, je les connais par mon
travail de journaliste, mais la plupart
des gens ne les connaissent pas et même
à la cantoche sans vente de même pas
simplement connaître le PIB parce que
ils ont pas besoin de connaître le
montant du PIB ni pour leur recherche et
donc pour leur carrière ni pour leur
enseignement.
Et depuis quelques années, j'ai pris
conscience de ça et une de mes
obsessions, c'est l'ignorance.
C'est-à-dire que encore une fois, je dis
ça très sérieusement, je ne connais pas
le pays dans lequel je vis. Je le sais.
Je travaille comme un taré pour essayer
de le comprendre le plus possible. Je
circule dans des endroits différents. Je
vais à BFM. J'ai des amis alternatives
économiques, j'ai des amis de gauche, de
droite. Je connais des gens qui sont
fonctionnaires, des gens qui sont dans
le privé. J'essaie de capter un maximum
d'information mais je sais que je ne
connais pas mon pays. Et ce qui me pose
un énorme problème, c'est de voir ma
fille au collège qui évidemment est
vissée sur sa chaise de 8h30 à 17h, ce
qui est sans équivalent dans aucun autre
pays européen, ce qui est quasiment sans
équivalent dans le monde, mis à part des
pays comme la Corée et qui ne va jamais
aller dans la boulangerie du quartier,
mais y aller pour de vrai pour savoir ce
que c'est qu'une boulangerie, pour
savoir comment on devient boulanger,
pour savoir comment le boulanger il
décide de produire quoi, à quel prix,
pourquoi l'apprenti il est payé autant.
Euh qu'est-ce que c'est que d'où vient
le blé ? Voyez que vraiment avec ses
profs, elle aille dans une boulangerie
mais sérieusement qu'elle aille assister
aux délibérations du conseil municipal,
qu'elle aille à un tribunal, qu'elle
aille discuter avec les gens des
transports en commun, qu'elle qu'elle
déjà qu'elle connaisse comment
fonctionne son collège, quel est le
budget du collège. Et évidemment quand
je repense à tous les grands débats des
années 60 et 70 sur l'autogestion que
mes étudiants, que les lycéens, que les
salariés aient quelque chose à dire sur
le fonctionnement de leur organisation.
Nous tous dans nos organisations, on est
des enfants, on est des mineurs au sens
juridique du terme. Moi, je n'ai aucun
espèce de voix, aucune espèce de voix
sur le fonctionnement de mon université.
Je ne connais même pas les gens qui la
dirigent. Ils me connaissent pas non
plus. Tout le monde s'en fout. Les
étudiants n'ont aucune espèce
de voilà,
ils subissent tout.
ce poulet décapité, ce manque de
socioperception,
cette incapacité à avoir un prisme de
lecture avec un spectre large pour
pouvoir anticiper la situation, ça nous
mène à quoi ? Ça nous mène à une élite
qui est complètement déconnectée, ça
tout le monde le sait.
Ça nous pousse des des ça nous pousse
des des idéologues économistes qui ne
connaissent pas leur pays.
Mais le français, lui qui travaille tous
les jours en respectant les règles du
jeu, en payant ses impôts, se voit, on
va dire son son train de vie, sa vie se
voit réduire comme pot de chagrin.
Vous en en terme en terme économique,
Ouais.
Qu'est-ce que ça va donner ? Ça ça va
nous emmener vers une crise gigantesque
sociale, ça c'est une certitude, tout le
monde le sent. On peut on peut le
certains maintenant le sentent dans leur
chair.
Donc ma question c'est comment on fait
pour reconnecter cette élite ? Parce que
le problème c'est on aura on aura beau
dégager tous les économistes,
l'institution va rester.
Qu'est-ce qu'on fait ?
Alors ce qui est marrant en plus savez
c'est qu'en France l'immense majorité
des économistes sont fonctionnaires. Et
donc moi ça me fascine toujours quand je
met mes collègues à la télé.
Vous êtes fonctionnaire aussi ? Ah, je
suis totalement fonctionnaire euh enfin
pour une partie de mes revenus parce que
mes mes revenus de fonctionnaires ne me
suffisent pas à à super célibataire en
région parisienne et mon mon salaire de
maître de confe ne me permet pas de
vivre.
Combien vous gagnez ?
Moi, je gagne 3000 €.
Net, brut,
net. Ouais, net. Euh, j'ai 47 ans.
Voilà. Et ça fait 30 ans depuis le
lycée. Je fais partie des des bourrins,
hein, des gens qui bossent comme un taré
depuis le lycée. J'ai calculé, ça fait
30 ans que je bosse. Voilà, le soir, le
weekend. J'ai écrit des centaines
d'articles dans la presse, des bouquins,
tout ça. Bon, j'en suis là, c'est assez
étonnant. Bref, euh effectivement, non
mais ce que je veux dire, c'est ça,
c'est quand même un problème. C'estàd
qu'aux États-Unis, ce que je préfère,
c'est qu'au moi, les mecs sont
cohérents. C'est-à-dire que les gars qui
sont économistes, ils sont profs dans
des facs privées avec des frais
d'inscription délirants, eux-mêmes, ils
ont des salaires délirants, ils sont
pour le marché, c'est cohérent. Mais
nous en France, tout le monde est
fonctionnaire. Vous avez des gens par
exemple, moi ça me fascine comme comment
il s'appelle Eric Vert. Eric Vert, il ne
fait que raller contre les dépenses
publiques. Mais le mec est une dépense
publique. Il a vécu toute sa vie au
crochet de l'État et hyper bien. Ces
gars-là, ils cumulent des retraites et
cetera. Ils ont des revenus extrêmement
élevés. Ils ont été financés, bibronnés
par l'État depuis François Fillon, hein,
plus jeune député de France. Les mecs,
il passent toute leur vie financé par
l'État. Pourquoi pas ? Mais il y a un
moment quand je entends parler de la
baisse des dépenses publiques ou de mes
collègues à la fac qui certains d'entre
eux sont très bien payés parce qu'il
cumulent plusieurs boulot en général
dans le public et ils sont profs à la
fac, ils sont prof à Polytechnique, ils
sont prof à l'énat. Tout ça c'est de
l'argent public. Des gens qui peuvent
gagner 10000 € par mois et qui viennent
vous expliquer sur les plateaux que il y
a pas assez de concurrence, qu'il y a
trop de dépenses publiques, que le RSA
ça coûte trop cher. Mais mon ami, mais
la première dépense publique c'est toi.
Vas-y, mais baisse ton salaire. Ça, je
pense qu'il y a un énorme problème là de
cohérence de nos élites. Moi, je préfère
100 fois plus quand on regarde par les
patrons de PME, les gens qui ont des
petits commerces et cetera. Bon, c'est
sûr qu'il y a peut-être un peu plus de
blag chez ces gens-là que des gens qui
sont fonctionnaires dont tous les
revenus sont déclarés.
C'est plus trop le cas.
Mais c'est vrai, notamment avec la avec
le développement des des paiements
bancaires,
la digitalisation.
Tout à fait. Ça a beaucoup réduit.
Exactement. C'est vrai. Bref, bon, en
tout cas, ce que nous disent les
statistiques, c'est que ces gens-là, ils
sont en gros au maximum à 3000 € par
mois en moyenne. Ils sont à 3000 € comme
moi. Mais ces gens-là, ils bossent deux
fois plus que moi.
Quel est quelle est la la le pourcentage
de la population qui touche le SMIC en
France ou autour du SMIC ?
Et ben, je sais pas. Euh mais euh ce
dont je suis sûr euh c'est que je pense
qu'il y a au moins la moitié de la
population française aujourd'hui qui euh
si on fait une liste simple,
c'est-à-dire avoir un logement où on se
sent bien, euh pouvoir acheter de la
bouffe bio pour pas choper un cancer,
partir en vacances, je dirais une fois
par an, aller au resto et au sinoche une
fois par mois, offrir voilà des
fringues, des bouquins
et des cadeaux deux fois par an à ses
gamins. Je pense que si on prend cette
liste là, il y a pas la moitié des gens
en France qui la satisfont.
Donc je parle pas de partir en vacances
à l'étranger, je parle pas même d'avoir
une voiture ou une voiture neuve. Je
pense que si on prend cette liste là, je
pense que la moitié des gens de notre
pays et peut-être même plus qui qui ne
la satisfont pas. Et donc il y a
effectivement pour répondre à ce que
vous disiez tout à l'heure euh alors
s'il m'écoutent, je leur fo leur fais un
grand coucou. Je suis en guerre contre
plein de gens. et notamment contre
l'INC, l'Institut national de la
statistique. Je sais que c'est des gens
très intègres, je sais que c'est des
gens très sérieux, mais le fait est que
en fait toutes nos statistiques sont
faussées parce que l'inflation est
sous-estimée.
C'est-à-dire que la hausse des prix,
telle qu'elle est calculée tous les ans,
n'est pas bonne. Elle est pas bonne pour
deux raisons. Je me parlais d'expliquer,
c'est pas très long, vous allez voir.
La première raison, c'est que euh voyez,
quand on vous dit un taux d'inflation,
d'où il sort ce chiffre ?
Alors, il y a un truc qui est hyper bien
fait par l'INC, c'est qu'il relève tous
les jours, tous les jours des dizaines
de milliers de prix aussi bien dans le
commerce physique que dans le commerce
en ligne. Ça, là-dessus, il y a rien à
dire. Bon, c'est très facile aujourd'hui
avec tous les catalogues et cetera. On a
une connaissance très très fine des prix
de vente, des biens de consommation.
Sauf que la première dépense des gens,
c'est quoi ? C'est le logement. C'est le
logement. C'est pas vos pots de yaourt.
C'est pas ça qui vous plombe le niveau
de vie. Or, l'INC fait un raisonnement
qui est juste sur le plan de la théorie
mais qui arrive à des résultats absurdes
en pratique qui est de dire que lorsque
vous endetttez pour acheter votre
logement, ça n'est pas une dépense de
consommation, ce qui est juste du point
de vue de la théorie économique, c'est
un investissement. Et donc les emprunts
immobiliers sont sortis du coût de la
vie.
Le résultat de tout ça, c'est que dans
le fameux panier de l'INC où on met la
voiture, les pots de yaourt, le
restaurant quand il y en avait, le
cinéma quand il y en avait, les livres
et cetera,
le poids du logement, tenez-vous bien,
c'est 7 %.
C'est 7 %. Donc là, on est totalement
dans le n'importe quoi. Mais évidemment,
l'INC, ils ont raison parce que en
théorie, ils ont raison. Ils sont
français, donc ils ont raison. Donc
quand on leur dit qu'ils ont tort, ils
vont répondre qu'ils ont raison parce
qu'ils ont raison. et ils ont ouvert un
blog, il y a un blog maintenant de l'INC
où ils expliquent très gentiment à la
française qu'ils ont raison parce qu'ils
ont raison. Bon, deuxième chose que fait
l'INC, c'est que l'INC, il y a un
problème. Alors là, c'est un petit peu
technique, vous allez voir, c'est quand
même pas si chiant. Il y a un problème,
c'est ce qu'on appelle l'effet qualité
hein. C'est que
tout le monde voit bien que la qualité
de ce qu'on achète change en permanence.
Et donc, comment vous comparez un
ordinateur d'aujourd'hui par rapport à
un ordinateur d' 10 ans ? Sachant que
l'ordinateur aujourd'hui est peut-être
100 fois plus puissant que l'ordinateur
y a 10 ans. Vous avez un vrai problème.
Ces deux biens ne sont pas comparables.
Donc quand vous comparez le prix sans
ajuster, vous faites une erreur. Ça
c'est un vrai problème. Et donc que fait
l'INC ? et bien elle ramène si vous
voulez la qualité
des deux biens au même niveau. Et donc
très concrètement et bien elle va vous
dire que votre ordinateur actuel vu que
supposons qu'il soit au même prix que
celui d'il y a 10 ans, vu qu'il est 100
fois plus puissant et ben dans l'indice
des prix on va dire qu'il vous coûte 100
fois moins cher.
D'accord ? Vous avez payé la même chose
mais qui est 100 fois mieux. Donc on va
vraiment dans les prix enlever ce qu'on
appelle l'effet qualité. Et sauf que
vous si vous avez acheté votre
ordinateur 1000 € vous l'avez acheté
1000 €. Donc quand on combine ces deux
effets, on a une sous-estimation très
importante de l'inflation. Or il y a
deux problèmes qui découlent et après
j'arrête, c'est que l'inflation est
calculée tous les ans. Donc cette erreur
qui est faite tous les ans, elle se
cumule.
D'autre part, tous les chiffres que vous
entendez et surtout que les ministres
ont sur leur bureau sur le niveau de
vie, comment est-ce qu'on calcule le
niveau de vie des Français ? On regarde
ce qui gagne et on enlève l'inflation.
Mais comme on enlève comme on comme on
n'enlève pas assez puisque l'inflation
est sous-estimée,
les gens qui nous gouvernent qui vont
bien pensent sincèrement que la
population a un niveau de vie très
supérieur à ce à celui qui est là. Et
donc là, on a un problème d'information
qui fait que toutes nos statistiques
sont fausses et sont très très fausses.
Et là, j'ai un problème, c'est que tous
mes amis de gauche, comme ils défendent
l'État, comme ils défendent l'INC, quand
on dit ça, on est un affreux populiste,
on dit n'importe quoi parce que c'est
des gens sérieux tout ça. Oui, c'est des
gens sérieux. Oui, pardon, je comprends
très bien ce qu'ils font. Oui, en
théorie, c'est cohérent, mais dans la
pratique, ça fait qu'il y a un
aveuglement de nos dirigeants parce
qu'on a et c'est dans tous les pays
comme ça, une surestimation considérable
du niveau de vie des gens, notamment à
cause de cette affreuse bulle
immobilière qui dure depuis 30 ou 40 ans
et qui est de toute évidence le premier
problème des gens, qui est le premier
problème du pays et dont personne ne
parle et dont non seulement personne ne
parle mais en plus quand vous regardez
la presse, les magazines, c'est toujours
la fête immobilier, ça repart. Mais mon
ami, ça repart pour qui ? pour les
locataires qui se ruinent pour acheter
un clapier à Paris. Et là, regardez la
presse actuellement, ça commence à cher
parce que pour la première fois, on a
une très légère stagnation du prix de
l'immobilier. Mais qu'est-ce que c'est
l'immobilier ? C'est des jeunes actifs
qui peuvent pas construire leur vie, qui
peuvent pas avoir d'enfants parce que
ils sont dans des logements trop petits
et pas du tout qu'à Paris. Pas du tout
qu'à Paris pour payer des loyers à des
vieux qui sont à la retraite qui ont une
meilleure retraite que eux leur salaire.
C'est ça la situation du pays. Et ça
c'est terrible parce que ça entretient
une guerre des âges dont on est qu'au
début. Donc moi ce que je ne comprends
pas c'est que quand on regarde la
réalité ou dans notre vie personnelle,
on cherche toujours à résoudre en
premier le plus gros problème. Et ben le
plus gros problème des gens c'est
l'immobilier. Mais là où on voit
justement l'économie c'est pas
rationnel. Là où on voit que l'économie
c'est que des croyances, comme me l'a
dit Bernard Maris euh quand j'étais son
collègue et que
paix à son âme et que je l'ai pas cru,
il me disait tout le temps ça. Il me
disait Gill, l'économie c'est que des
croyances. J'ai Mais non Bernard, c'est
des mécanismes, taux de change, taux
d'intérêt, déficit, inflation. Moi je
voulais être un bon économiste
scientifique qui observe la rarité. Dis
non c'est que des croyances. Et je je
pensais qu'il exagérait et cetera. Mais
sur l'immobilier, qu'est-ce qui se passe
? Discutez-en autour de vous. Les gens
se réjouissent de la hausse. Les gens
sont contents quand vous avez vu ma
maison elle a pris 100000 €. Bah ouais
gros gros malin. Et pourquoi et pourquoi
tes enfants ils galèrent ? Pourquoi ils
arrivent pas à se loger ? Bah parce que
les prix ont augmenté. Donc toi ta
maison elle a pris 100000 € mais
qu'est-ce que ça t'a apporté ? Qu'est-ce
que ça change à ta vie ? Rien. Et par
contre tu as tes enfants qui galèrent,
tu as tes petits enfants qui galèrent et
tu vois pas le rapport. Et en fait
justement la révolution conservatrice de
Rean et Satcher dans les années 80.
Qu'est-ce qu'elle fait Margarette
Satcher ? Quelle est la mesure la plus
géniale et la plus intelligente qu'elle
prend ? Elle permet aux habitants des
logements sociaux, des HLM anglais
d'acheter leur logement. Pourquoi ?
Parce qu'elle sait que quand tu deviens
propriétaire, tu votes à droite tout
simplement. Et ça, toutes les études le
montrent. À revenu égal, quand tu es
propriétaire, tu as quelque chose à
perdre. Donc tu crains l'instabilité
sociale, tu crains l'imposition, tu
penses comme un riche, même si en fait
tu es toujours pauvre, tu te penses
comme propriétaire alors qu'en fait tu
es endetté et donc tu votes à droite. Et
aujourd'hui cette idéologie est dans
toutes les têtes. Et les gens en fait
sont contents de cette catastrophe
totale parce que c'est quoi la
conséquence de l'augmentation du prix de
l'immobilier ? Bah, c'est qu'il y a des
ghetos, c'est qu'il y a des
centre-villes où les entreprises ne
peuvent plus fonctionner parce que les
loyers sont délirants. La rente, ce
qu'on appelle la rente, la rente
urbaine, la rente immobilière, vous la
payez pas que dans le loyer, vous la
payez tout le temps puisque ça fait
augmenter tous les prix. Pourquoi les
commerces sont aussi chers ? Pourquoi le
commerce de détail aussi cher ? Parce
que le patron du magasin, lui aussi,
doit payer un loyer des liants. Pourquoi
le café est aussi cher dans les
centre-villes ? Parce que le patron du
bar, lui aussi, doit payer un loyer.
Donc, votre prix du logement, c'est pas
juste chez vous. C'est dans tous vos
achats.
Et ça donc ça fait ça fait des ghetaos
de riches. C'est ça.
Mais ça fait des getos de riches et ça
fait des ghetaos de pauvres. C'est ce
qu'on a connu dans toutes les familles.
Les gens qui doivent s'éloigner très
loin de leur lieu de travail parce que
ils ne peuvent absolument pas vivre près
de là où ils travaillent et donc ça a
des conséquences humaines terribles.
Donc là là on va recentrer un peu plus
dans l'actualité.
La crise du Covid, corrigez-moi si je me
trompe, à peu près 70 % du PIB, c'est
c'est de la consommation intérieure.
C'est ça,
on est d'accord ?
Non, c'est non, je pense que c'est moins
que bon, en tout cas, c'est plus c'est
plus de la moitié du PB. Ouais, ça c'est
sûr.
C'est plus de la moitié du PB.
Et donc là, on a une crise où tous les
business sont impactés, tout le monde
est mis en, on va dire, en hypothermie
de business carrément. H
ils sont ils sont en train de dormir
après une petite saison hivernale mais
l'hiver continue.
C'est ça.
Qu'est-ce qui va se passer ? On va se
prendre un mur dans la tête
h
que jamais aucun politique n'a été amené
à gérer. Mis à part pendant les guerres
3945.
Vous tablez sur combien de récessions ?
- 10 - 15 - 20 %.
Bon, l'année dernière en gros on a fait
- 10 hein et 10 mais avec les subsides
de l'État,
c'est ça ? Non mais on a quand même fait
on a
c'est des moins des faux- 10.
Voilà. Mais c'est le c'est le enfin vous
avez raison au sens où la réalité est
pire parce qu'en fait effectivement la
voilà c'est comme si c'est comme si vous
avez le cancer, on sait que vous allez
mourir mais là aujourd'hui vous êtes
toujours vivant. Donc voilà, c'est ça,
c'est ça la situation de l'économie
française l'année dernière, c'est que
euh voilà, il y a plein d'entreprises
qui ont chopé le cancer mais qui sont
pas mortes. Et donc on a eu
zombies les z ces fameuses ces fameuses
entreprises zombies. Alors c'est sûr
qu'il y a une incertitude de dire les
aides euh franchement là je sais pas et
personne ne sait et je pense c'est pas
gênant de dire qu'on sait pas. Par
exemple, si on prend les les
restaurateurs,
ils se plaignent beaucoup publiquement
et ils ont totalement raison. En privé,
il y en a pas mal qui vous disent "En
fait moi ça va parce que justement avec
l'aide de 10000 € par mois, mes salariés
trouent touchent le chômage partiel. Moi
justement j'ai que mon loyer à payer et
en fait ça va. Donc il y a je pense que
il y a peut-être un peu moins
d'entreprises que ce qu'on craint qui
vont faire définitivement faillite. Par
contre là vous avez raison et ce qui est
sûr et là aussi les modèles de des
économies sont complètement faux c'est
qu'on a toujours l'image euh qui est
l'image si vous voulez comme dans la
dans la physique que vous voyez on a des
courbes, vous avez de la récession puis
après ça remonte. Mais en fait, cette
image, elle est profondément fausse.
C'est-à-dire que l'année dernière, il y
a des gens qui ont perdu leur emploi de
façon définitive. Et quand vous perdez
votre emploi au même moment de votre
vie, par exemple, typiquement moi si ça
m'arrivait ou des gens de 50 ans dans la
mauvaise région, c'est fini pour vous.
Vous le savez. Vous le savez. Pourquoi
est-ce que les gens se battent autant
quand on ferme une usine ? Parce qu'ils
connaissent l'avenir. Ils savent ce qui
va leur arriver. Ils savent qu'ils vont
retrouver un boulot beaucoup moins bien,
beaucoup moins intéressant ou peut-être
rien du tout.
La récession pour 2021, c'est combien de
pourcent ? Bah moi je pense qu'il y aura
pas de récession de 2021 mais pour une
mauvaise raison, c'est parce que on
compare d'une année sur l'autre et la
récession cachée, elle va être de
combien ? Je je sais pas mais ce que je
sais par contre
il y a une étude très importante qui a
été écrite par le FMI qui est disponible
en français qui est vraiment très facile
à lire qui a été publié en novembre
dernier
qui est qui est bouleversante. J'ai
jamais lu ça dans une publication du
fond monétaire international qui
s'appelle l'ombre permanente d'un
démarrage malheureux.
Voilà. Et euh rien que l'image qui a été
choisie est très impressionnante, c'est
sur la jeunesse. Et en fait, qu'est-ce
que nous disent les économistes du FMI ?
Ils nous disent, "On connaît l'avenir
euh des jeunes gens qui ont été diplômés
en mai 2020." On connaît l'avenir de ces
gens-là. Comment ? Parce que on a
beaucoup d'outils de mesure en économie.
On en a certains qui sont très bons et
on connaît ce qui est arrivé aux coortes
passé, aux gens qui ont eu le malheur
d'arriver sur ce qu'on appelle le marché
du travail au moment d'une récession et
on peut voir ce qui deviennent 5 ans, 10
ans, 15 ans, 20 ans plus tard. On le
sait tout ça et on le sait non seulement
sur leur revenus mais aussi sur des
variables qualitatives sur leur état de
santé parce que il y a des études
épidémiologique là on parle beaucoup
d'épidémiologie mais il y a tout le
temps des grandes études
épidémiologiques dans les pays riches où
on suit des dizaines des centaines de
milliers de gens pendant des décennies.
C'est c'est prodigieux la connaissance
qui est produite par les institutions de
recherche publique c'est absolument
extraordinaire. Bref, on sait donc et
moi ça me concerne directement puisque
j'ai des étudiants que je connais qui
sont typiquement dans ce cas-là que les
gens qui ont été diplômés en mai 2020
vont avoir une vie qui va être beaucoup
plus difficile que les gens qui ont été
diplômés quelques années auparavant pour
une raison simple, c'est que là ces
gens-là, ils cherchent du travail depuis
mai l'année dernière, depuis quasiment 1
an et évidemment ils n'en trouvent pas.
Et la récession comme vous dites
effectivement va continuer pendant
peut-être encore 1 an 2 ans. Et quand
l'économie repartira
quand l'économie reparti
quand l'économie repartira si elle
repart parce que c'est pas du tout sûr
en fait qu'elle reparte vraiment et bien
au moment où les entreprises vont quand
même finir par reprendre les embauches
parce qu'il y aura des gens qui sont
partis à la retraite parce que il y aura
quand même des secteurs qui vont aller
mieux et bien ces jeunes gens-là on ne
va pas les prendre parce qu'on prendra
ceux qui arriveront sur le marché du
travail à ce moment-là.
Et donc eux, les gens qui sont été
diplômés l'année dernière ou peut-être
même ceux qui vont être encore être
diplômés cette année, ça sera le deuxème
choix, ça sera la le trème choix. Et en
France particulièrement,
votre début de carrière est un très bon
prédicteur de l'ensemble de votre vie.
Évidemment, il y a toujours des cas
individuels. Évidemment, chacun peut
avoir une vie merveilleuse et cetera,
mais moi ce qui m'intéresse, c'est les
moyennes. Parce que pour comprendre ce
qui se passe, c'est les moyennes. Et en
moyenne, en France, on sait que lorsque
vous commencez votre vie active ou
justement vous la commencez pas dans une
récession, ça a un impact sur votre
qualité de vie, sur l'ensemble de votre
vie. Et ça, ce résultat, on l'avait pour
des récessions de blagues. Par exemple,
bon, les gens s'en souviennent pas et
c'est normal, en 1993, il y a une
récession assez importante en France
pour des problèmes de taux de change de
système monétaire européen, tout ça,
c'est très vieux. Et on sait justement
que la génération 1993 a une carrière
salariale beaucoup moins sympa que celle
d'avant et celle d'après. Et là, comme
vous le dites très justement, on a une
récession qui est absolument colossale
masqué
ou non ? pas masqué parce que l'année
dernière par exemple bon là justement
mes chers amis de l'INC ils ont affiché
moins 10 % et vos amis de la Banque de
France ils disent queon va avoir plus 5
%.
Ouais moi j'aime beaucoup mes amis de la
Banque de France qui sont payés trois
fois comme moi. J'ai pris une grosse
claque il y a quelques années
10 fois comme vous.
Ouais peut-être 10 fois. J'ai eu un
étudiant, un très bon étudiant euh mais
bon qui a terminé ses études après le
master et son salaire d'embauche à la
Banque de France à l'époque euh donc un
niveau relativement bas pour la Banque
de France était nettement supérieur au
salaire que j'avais. Ça me ça m'avait
bien calmé. Euh bon, sachant que le
patron, la Banque de France aussi,
quelqu'un qui est tout le temps dans les
médias pour nous expliquer qu'il faut
baisser les dépenses publiques. Je vous
laisse juste chercher sa rémunération
annuel. Je pense ça va vous faire ça va
vous faire votre soirée. Et donc là, ils
me font bien rire effectivement les gens
de la Banque de France, mais ça pose
vraiment un très gros problème. C'est
qu'il continue en permanence à faire des
projections sur 2021, 2022, 2023 alors
que personne et eux-mêmes non plus
évidemment ne connaît la situation de
l'économie française la semaine
prochaine. Et donc, mais il continue et
voyez, ça revient vraiment à ce problème
de la connaissance. ces gens-là qui sont
des gens très brillants, qui sont
toujours sur des gens très gentils, qui
pourraient être des amis.
Pourquoi vous dites qu'ils sont
brillants ?
Bah parce que c'est extrêmement dur de
rentrer dans la dur de quoi ? C'est
c'est vous savez
non ça je non ça je alors ça je pense
que c'est une grosse erreur parce que
pour l'avoir vécu
les rats de laboratoire vous les faites
bosser suffisamment ils font médecine
hein. Ouais. Alors ça je pense justement
c'est une très grosse erreur et euh
évidemment ça va être dur de dire ça
sans donner l'impression de plaider pour
ma chapelle, mais je pense que les gens
qui critiquent à juste titre les grandes
écoles dont je fais partie ne se rendent
pas compte parce qu'ils l'ont pas vécu
donc c'est normal qu'ils le sachent pas
de l'incroyable dureté du système
scolaire français de l'incroyable
difficulté qu'il y a et à rentrer à
l'ENAT à Polytechnique ou je je non non
mais je permets je continuer et je
permets de le dire ou comme je l'ai fait
à l'école normale supérieure. Et ce que
je veux dire par là, c'est que je
défends pas du tout le système, c'est
qu'au contraire, c'est beaucoup trop
dur.
Mais c'est dur dans quel sens ?
C'est-à-dire qu'il faut faire la lèche
pour rentrer dans le moule.
Ah non, absolument pas. C'est-à-dire que
à l'âge à partir de 15 ans, à l'âge où
tout le monde a envie de sortir, de
vivre et cetera, vous vous êtes enfermé
avec vos bouquins parce que vos notes de
seconde sont décisives pour l'entrée en
classe préparatoire. Donc moi euh j'ai
fait un bac scientifique à l'époque à
partir de C'est ça.
Ouais. Le fameux bac S. à partir de 15
ans.
Bax peut-être non
et même un back bien vu. C'était en 91
euh à partir de l'âge voyez 15 ans c'est
tout petit hein, vous êtes tout petit.
Vous croyez vous êtes grand à 15 ans,
vous êtes tout petit. À partir de l'âge
de 15 ans, littéralement je jouais mon
avenir sur chaque interro de math,
chaque interro de physique. Voilà donc
ça la seconde, la première, la
terminale. Première année de prépa,
c'est la torture. Le système de prépa en
France est une honte absolue. On vous
humilie. Vous aviez l'habitude d'avoir
18 de moyenne, vous tapez des quatre.
des sur 20. Moi, j'ai connu des colles,
ce qu'on appelle les coles en math où
vous êtes justement collé littéralement
au tableau, vous êtes trois en
concurrence parce que c'est un concours.
Donc là, c'est faut bouffer les autres
he et vous avez un correcteur qui vous
donne un sujet totalement habitable qui
reste les bras croisés. Et moi j'ai
connu là, moi qui étais un excellent
élève, la terreur au tableau, je ne
comprenais pas ce qu'il fallait faire.
J'avais aucune idée. J'étais en panique,
je voulais sortir de là. Une parenthèse,
est-ce que ce système scolaire ou
discolaire
est en train de sélectionner les plus
toxiques pour notre société ?
Alors, c'est pas impossible, mais je
finis juste mon histoire, pardon. Donc,
vous faites ça, une première année de
prépa, une deuxème année de prépa,
certains une trisème année de prépa.
Quand vous rentrez dans les grandes
écoles, d'accord, vous avez mangé 5 ou 6
ans de votre vie, mais vous êtes dans un
état lamentable.
Psychologiquement parlant,
psychologiquement, physiquement. Et en
plus, les épreuves sont objectivement
extrêmement difficiles. Vous
vous vengez quand vous arrivez.
Il y a une étape qui est très
importante. Euh, et c'est là où tout se
joue, c'est que quand vous rentrez,
comme ça m'est arrivé dans ces
établissements hyper prestigieux, vous
avez un grand débile qui vous dit "Vous
êtes l'élite de la nation."
Pourquoi et débile ?
Ben parce que personne personne n'est
l'élite de rien. Surtout vous êtes des
gamins, vous connaissez strictement rien
de la vie
quand on voit le résultat.
Ouais. Mais même sans parler de ça, si
je veux dire cette idée d'élite, elle
est complètement enfin c'est juste c'est
just qu'on on vous rembourse votre
scolarité làin.
Non mais je veux dire vous êtes juste
bon dans un domaine mais par exemple moi
j'ai jamais pensé que j'avais quoi que
ce soit de meilleur que un artisan que
un gars qui a commencé qui a apprentient
ouisto à 14 ans. Non non mais attendez
non mais je pense que c'est très très
important pour les gens de savoir ça
parce que pardon moi ça je l'ai vécu. Je
l'ai vécu dans ma chair. J'ai raté des
concours, j'ai raté Science Po raté la
prépa à chaussé.
Comment vous avez fait pour aller rater
Science Po ?
Bah je sais pas, j'étais pas
pas la bonne carte politique. Mais bon,
vous ayez pas dans les bonnes soirées
peut-être. C'est ça
ce que je veux dire par là.
Est-ce que vous
Non mais ce que je veux dire par là non
mais
vous êtes 10 Non mais on n pas sur BFM
ici, d'accord ? Non parce que si si moi
je me lève, je fais 110 kg et je me
lève, je vous assois tout de suite sur
votre chaise.
Ça vous fait marrer ça va pas vous faire
marrer longtemps.
Non mais c'est que si on veut comprendre
ce qui est-ce qu'on veut comprendre le
fonctionnement de la société française,
ce que je veux dire c'est que les gens
qui nous dirigent, ils ont vécu ça,
c'est un automatisme de BFM,
c'est-à-dire essayer de parler sur
l'autre. C'est bien, je vous ai laissé
parler maintenant, je vais vous poser ma
question.
Ouais.
Vous êtes prof, d'accord ? Est-ce que ce
système scolaire est en train de
sélectionner les plus toxiques, les plus
dangereux pour notre société ? Est-ce
qu'on est en train d'en gros de donner à
la classe des psychopathes mégalot qui
n'ont aucune capacité de remise en
question ? Vous pensez au discours des
hier ou quoi ? qui n'ont aucune capacité
de remise en question et tout le monde
ferme les yeux parce que ça fait bien.
On élève des petits requins pour un
monde de requins.
Bah j'ai pas de réponse à cette question
mais moi par contre ce que je pense très
sincèrement c'est que là où vous vous
trompez de cible euh c'est
qu'aujourd'hui le pouvoir n'est plus du
tout dans l'état. C'est qu'aujourd'hui
dans la haute administration cette
petite caisse qui est pas capable de
commander des masques
plus non plus. Non non, les les gens qui
comptent en France c'est le PDG de la
société générale.
C'est lui qui compte
Frédéric Coua, il a rien demandé.
Qu'est-ce qu'il dit ? Bon, je sais que
la société générale est pas dans un très
bon état, mais pourquoi vous parlez
Frédéric Gouder ? Non, c'est le PDG de
Renault. C'est ces gens-là qui font le
pays. C'est même d'ailleurs beaucoup
plus, voyez, par exemple là, il y a
plein d'objets autour de nous. Quels
sont les gens qui font la France ? C'est
les architectes.
C'est ça les gens qui créent ce qu'il y
a autour de nous. C'est les ingénieurs
qui font tous ces trucs là. C'est ça ces
gens-là qui font la France. Ce que nous
ressentons, les émotions que nous
vivons, ces rues hyper bruyantes de
Paris, elles sont pas faites par moi,
elles sont pas faites par les profs,
elles sont pas faites par les Éarques,
elles sont pas faites par les ministres,
elles sont faites par les architectes,
les ingénieurs, les les gens qui
fabriquent des objets qui décident de la
forme de ma voiture. Ce sont ces gens-là
qui ont qui ont des entreprises
aujourd'hui, des entreprises françaises,
il faut le savoir. Sont parmi les plus
grandes multinationales du monde. C'est
pour ça que je cite la société générale.
On le sait pas mais en France la BNP
PIB, la société générale sont parmi les
plus grandes banques du monde. Ce sont
des gens-là les décisions de façon là en
tant que scientifique, les décisions que
prend prennent ces gens-là affectent
littéralement des centaines de milliers
de gens dans le monde.
Pour ça qu'on a sauvé la Grèce.
Bah
alors en fait c'est assez marrant
l'idée. Ça c'est assez marrant. Et ça
c'est très intéressant l'exemple de la
Grèce parce que quand vous êtes là,
imaginons on est allemand d'accord donc
j'ai un short ridicule, des chaussettes,
des sandales.
Les allemands n'ont pas des sandales et
des shorts ridicules. Faut arrêter avec
ce stéréotype.
Bon imaginons que je sois allemand,
qu'on soit tous allemands là
et ben on sait tous, d'accord ? On sait
tous qu'on a aidé la Grèce.
Et ben cette ce savoir, cette certitude
est empiriquement fausse. Les gens
peuvent chercher en 2 secondes.
L'Allemagne a gagné et a gagné des
milliards d'euros en prêtant à la Grèce
tout simplement parce que l'Allemagne a
prêté à la Grèce avec intérêt et que la
Grèce a remboursé plus à l'Allemagne que
ce que l'Allemagne lui a prêté. Donc ça
c'est très intéressant. C'est-à-dire que
c'est un fait sociologique massif. C'est
un fait politique massif. En Allemagne,
tous les gens savent qu'ils se sont
saignés pour la Grèce. Ils le savent.
C'est une certitude. Et bien la réalité,
c'est l'inverse. C'est que ce sont
l'Allemagne s'est enrichie et c'est dans
la presse économique. C'est dans des
articles de la tribune des échos. Est-ce
qu'on a sauvé la Grèce pour sauver la
société générale et les banques
françaises ?
Voilà, on n pas sauvé la Grèce.
Qu'est-ce qui s'est passé ? Il y a des
articles de mon collègue Michel Husson
qui expliquait ça déjà à l'époque. Euh
là aussi he vraiment les médias français
n'ont pas du tout fait leur travail qui
était quand même très facile à faire.
c'est que lorsqu'il y a eu les fameux
plans de sauvetage de la Grèce, il faut
savoir qu'à ce moment-là physiquement,
c'est pour ça qu'il faut toujours
revenir à l'aspect matériel de la vie.
Où allait l'argent ? L'argent n'allait
pas en Grèce. 90 % des sommes allaient
aux banques françaises et allemandes qui
avaient prêté beaucoup trop à la Grèce.
Et pourquoi ces banques avaient prêté à
la Grèce ? Parce que la Grèce versait
des taux d'intérêt plus élevés que les
autres pays. Donc littéralement,
l'argent n'allait pas en Grèce. Mais
l'affichage politique évidemment c'était
de dire "On sauve les Grecs" parce que
l'euro et cetera, la démocratie, l'Union
européenne et la paix sur la terre et
les petits oiseaux. Et il y a pas eu un
seul journaliste dans aucun grand média
qui a été simplement capable de lire les
communiers de presse.
Ils sont peut-être pas capables,
ils sont totalement capables, mais juste
ils ont ils ont voilà, ils ont des
soirées à faire, ils ont quatre
émissions par semaine, voilà par mois,
ça leur suffit pas et cetera. Enfin, ils
ont des vrais soucis dans la vie quoi.
Ils sont pas tous comme ça hein.
Ah bah si si justement bah si vous
prenez disons des noms hein, euh vous
prenez Anne Sophie Lapix, vous prenez
Laurent de Lausse, vous prenez Gill
Boulot. Ce sont des gens qui sont
extrêmement riches euh qui ont beaucoup
trop d'émissions et qui ne considèrent
pas que leur travail c'est de travailler
justement et d'informer les gens qui
font partie d'une espèce d'industrie du
spectacle et dont contre qui
effectivement comme je suis aussi
journaliste, j'ai une très grande colère
parce que ces gens-là sont en train de
ruiner la profession de journaliste aux
yeux de la population, sont en train de
très fortement abîmer la démocratie
parce que simplement ils ne font pas le
minimum de leur minimum du travail.
Quand comme d'autres personnes, je passe
du temps sur Twitter dans la journée, on
voit passer des informations précises,
des informations importantes, que ça
concerne les mensonges énormes de
Jean-Michel Blanquaire, que ça concerne
euh il y a plus d'un an euh la question
des violences policières, regardz par
j'ai regardé le journal de France 2
quasiment tous les soirs, a
littéralement mis des mois des mois à
aborder la question des violences
policières au moment des manifestations
des gilets jaunes avant même de savoir
on reviendra sur ce sujet un peu plus
tard pour c'est quoi les mensonges de
blan selon vous ?
Ah bah tout
tout. C'est-à-dire que Jean-Michel
Blanquer euh qui littéralement à la télé
avant même le Covid avant même le Covid
Blanca est à la télé à la radio tous les
jours. Il sort des statistiques
complètement fausses et il n'y a aucun
journaliste qui lui demande d'où vient
ce chiffre. Et donc par exemple, il a
menti sur le taux d'incidence. Euh il
vous m bah par exemple ça fait 4 ans
qu'il nous explique qu'il y avoir une
augmentation de la rémunération des
enseignants. Donc tout le monde sait
qu'elle n'aura pas lu. De toute façon
c'est le quinquena est terminé mais tous
les journalistes ont repris ces annonces
et ce que je ne comprends littéralement
pas là en tant que journaliste, c'est
qu'est-ce qui se passe dans la tête des
gens pour continuer à inviter ces
gens-là en ne faisant pas votre travail
par ailleurs. C'est-à-dire que vous
savez, je veux dire enfin vous savez que
vraiment vous la presse c'est vraiment
un des piliers les plus importants de la
démocratie. Donc vous savez que vous
avez quelqu'un, vous accueillez
quelqu'un qui est très fort dans sa
communication, qui a une équipe derrière
lui qui va vous dire n'importe quoi,
vous allez pas le contredire, vous allez
vérifier aucun fait. Alors que même en
temps réel, ça m'est arrivé sur Twitter,
vous avez des gens, des profs qui disent
"C'est pas vrai, je peux témoigner et
cetera." Pourquoi simplement Jean-Michel
Blanquer dans les grands médias n'est
jamais mis face à des enseignants ?
Il faut interdire il faut interdire les
cours d'éloquences à Science Po c'est ça
la prise de contrôle de la dialectique ?
Ben, je pense, par exemple, on on fait
des grands discours sur la démocratie.
Euh, je pense par exemple que le le pays
serait très différent si euh les
matinales radio
interrogaient des vrais gens tout
simplement. C'est-à-dire que euh alors
ça risque pas d'arriver avec la campagne
présidentielle puisque les gars savent
que les ministres viennent et que les
mecs ont plus aucune éthique. C'estd que
vous avez Marline Chapa, Gérald Armanin
et cetera. C'est des gens qui assument
totalement le fait de dire n'importe
quoi, de dévaloriser leur fonction
extrêmement prestigieuse et importante
de la société de ministres
pour eux. pour eux peut-être qu'il ne
ils ne disent pas n'importe quoi.
Oui, enfin toujours
quand vous avez qui dit qu'elle sait pas
mettre les masques, ça on sait
pertinemment qu'elle est persuadé de ça.
En tout cas ce que je moi ce que j'ai
moi ça fait des années que j'écoute plus
les matinales à cause de ça mais je
revois passer les trucs sur les réseaux
sociaux pendant la journée. Ce que je
veux dire c'est que on apprend rien. On
apprend rien. Et je reviens à ce
problème de la connaissance. Des gens
comme les Salamé euh connaissent très
très mal la France, connaissent très
très bien une certaine partie de la
France et sont persuadés de tout savoir
parce que sont persuadés d'être génial
ou lutte contre leur complexe
d'infériorité par rapport à d'autres
gens, j'en sais rien. Mais en tout cas,
moi ce que j'aimerais vraiment, surtout
que c'est un petit peu payé avec mes
impôts, c'est entendre un prof de lycée,
c'est entendre une caissière. Mais
vraiment et ce qui est assez drôle quand
j'en parle autour de moi dans le milieu
des journalistes, "Ah mais ces gens-là,
il faut les préparer, c'est compliqué."
Bah ouais, mais tu fais ton boulot, mon
ami. Et puis en fait, il y a plein de
gens qui savent s'exprimer normalement.
Enfin, je dire tout le monde. Et puis
s'il y a des hésitations,
s'il y a du stress, bah justement il se
passe quelque chose. C'est vrai. Là, on
a des robots. Enfin, c'est d'une
tristesse ce qui se passe. On n jamais
eu. Moi, j'ai je bouffe de la politique
depuis que je suis tout petit parce que
dans ma famille vraiment c'était le truc
de quel milieu socioculturel ? Moi, mes
deux parents sont cadre de la fonction
publique
et euh donc j'ai jamais connu des tels
robots, personne n'a jamais connu des
tels robots depuis 30 ou 40 ans avec les
fameux éléments de l'orgaage. Je veux
dire aujourd'hui une des meilleures
enfin c'est quand même prodigur
aujourd'hui une des meilleures
informations euh émission d'information
de France sur les grands médias c'est
quotidien. C'estàd que quotidien quand
simplement ils laissent tourner leur
caméras et qu'il montrent la mise en
scène des conférences de presse,
pourquoi c'est pas au 20h ça ? Et par
contre, je vois que le le 20h donc que
je regarde beaucoup que vous avez ça m'a
marqué ou les grandes émissions
régulièrement ils vous disent "Ah ah on
va débunquer la la fake news qui circule
sur internet" et pendant 5 minutes, il
se manque des gros débiles qui cru à la
vidéo truqué sur internet. Mais moi ce
que j'aimerais déjà c'est qu'ils nous
disent "Aujourd'hui, on a choisi de
traiter sur le sujet. On a choisi." Et
pourquoi ils nous font 10 minutes sur la
neige quand il neige ? Moi quand je suis
rentré chez moi, je sais qu'il a neigé,
je l'ai vécu. Pourquoi tu me fais 10
minutes sur la neige ? Qu'est-ce que tu
m'apprends ? Par contre, il y a des
sujets centraux qui sont jamais abordés.
Les accidents du travail.
Les accidents du travail. Tous les
jours, il y a des gens qui meurent en
France dans leur travail. Tous les jours
et pas qu'un peu. Ce sujet n'est jamais
traité. Jamais. Par contre l'hiver,
Laurent de Laousse, il nous fait 5
minutes sur 30. 5 minutes sur les
stations de ski parce qu'on a bien
compris qu'il adorait le ski. Ça
concerne personne en France. Oui oui,
c'est c'est un peu comme la météo, il y
a le le si on dit qu'il fait mauvais en
Bretagne, ça tue le tourisme en
Bretagne. S'il fait ses 5 minutes sur le
le les stations de ski, c'est peut-être
aussi euh pour envoyer un peu de
business aux stations de ski, non ?
Le problème c'est que la raison pour
laquelle il le fait, moi je m'en fous
profondément parce que déjà moi je
m'ennuie je regarde le 20h pour mon
travail pour m'informer comme je dis
parce que tout n'est pas mauvais et dans
quasiment chaque journal de 20h pas
toujours, mais je vais il y a au moins 3
minutes où je vais apprendre quelque
chose. Ce que je dire je vais découvrir
un métier, je vais découvrir un problème
en France, à l'étranger, je vais me dire
"Bah tiens là, il y a un truc
intéressant." Moi, j'ai tout le temps,
je suis tout le temps à la recherche
d'information parce qu'encore une fois,
je sais que je ne connais pas mon pays,
que je ne connais pas le monde, que je
connais pas tous les problèmes et donc
je suis tout le temps à la recherche
d'information. Donc, j'ai besoin de ces
gens-là et je ne comprends pas qu' il ne
se réveillent pas avec les gens autour
d'eux. Les rédactions ne se réveillent
pas.
Vous avez pas besoin de ces gens-là.
Je pense vous faites un fil Twitter
correct, un fil Facebook correct avec
des gens qui sont aux manettes. Par
exemple, vous prenez des gars qui
travaillent dans les centrales
nucléaires, qui vous tiennent au courant
de ce qui se passe sur les protocoles de
sécurité des des ainsi de suite et vous
prenez ça. C'està-dire vous bypassez les
sculpteurs d'air chaud et vous avez plus
besoin de ces gens-là.
Oui. Alors là, vous avez raison
effectivement, c'est que euh ça c'est
une situation que j'ai beaucoup de mal à
appréhender. Je pense que je suis pas le
seul.
C'est le journal de venteur qui vous
appelle. C'est ça.
Pour pour soit aller chercher de l'info,
soit confirmer une info.
On l'a vécu plusieurs fois. Alors là,
c'est vrai que pour prendre le
contrepied de ce que je viens de dire
précédemment, c'est vrai que quand mes
étudiants râent contre les médias, je
leur dis "Les amis, moi par rapport à
l'époque où j'avais votre âge, il y a un
accès à l'information qui est
prodigieux. Il y a plein de chaînes
gratuites en plus. Il y a des trucs sur
YouTube, il y a des il y a des médias en
ligne gratuits qui font euh
qui donne l'accès à une quantité
d'information qui est très
impressionnante. Et donc là
effectivement, il y a une sorte de
balcanisation de l'accès à
l'information. Donc je sais pas très
bien là où elle nous mène, mais euh
quand j'essaie d'être un petit peu
optimiste, ce j'ai ce que j'ai vraiment
beaucoup de mal à faire, je me dis que
là euh on s'aime peut-être quelques
graines euh que effectivement les médias
mainstream vont arriver à se rendre
compte un peu de ce qui se passe, que il
y aura des gens qui vont circuler d'un
médiia à l'autre, que il y a des gens
qui vont avoir accès à la formation en
tant que public et cetera. Cela dit, moi
ce que je dis à mes étudiants par
exemple, c'est que euh il faut aussi un
moment être cohérent dans ces choix.
Alors eux, je sais que ils ont beaucoup
moins de ils ont des problèmes
financiers, mais il y a quand même
beaucoup de gens en France euh qui ont
le moyen d'acheter de la presse et qui
choisissent de pas le faire, hein, et
qui chouent en disant machin, mais qui
partent en vacances à l'étranger trois
fois par an et qui pleurent en disant
"Oh là, l'état de la presse et tout."
Mais mon ami, il y a de la presse de
qualité. Alors là vraiment il y en a en
France mais il y a un moment il faut
payer. Et c'est ça que j'aime bien dans
la profession d'économiste, c'est que un
des trucs des économistes c'est de dire
"OK, tu blablades comme je fais là et
c'est quoi ton comportement ?" C'est
quoi ton comportement ? He comme disent
les Américains et une expression des
États-Unis c'est "Do you walk the talk
?" Hein ? Est-ce que tu marches le
blabla ? Si je traduis littéralement,
"Do you walk the talk ? Est-ce que tu
mets l'argent ?" Il y a une autre
expression qui dit "Est-ce que tu mets
l'argent là où ta bouche est ?" Et donc
moi je vois beaucoup de gens notamment
de gauche qui pleurent et cetera, mais
mon ami mais essaie déjà d'avoir un
comportement cohérent par rapport à ça.
Donc achète de la presse, vote pour des
partis qui défendent les services
publics et cetera. Et cela évidemment je
pense que c'est le cœur du problème de
l'écologie, c'est qu'on est tous
terrifiés par l'effondrement écologique.
On va revenir en fait on a pas envie. On
va on va revenir après à ça.
Donc si je synthise un peu votre pensée,
on a une un enseignement économique qui
est digne d'un poulet sans tête qui
marche sans sa tête. On a une presse qui
est l'équivalent de la tête qui roule
par terre, qui suit la pente.
Revenons aux perspectives.
Ouais. Et nos perspectives économiques,
elles en sont où ? On va se retrouver à
à d'autres ligées de la tête. On va se
retrouver
comme le Portugal en 1950. On va se
retrouver comment ? Est-ce que est-ce
que les Français saisissent bien la
vitesse qu'on a pris et le mur qui nous
attend ? Est-ce que vous pouvez leur
expliquer un petit peu la boucherie
gigantesque
qui va arriver ? Parce que mis à part
donc là, on va on va faire la minute.
Mis à part la banque. Non, ça vous fait
marrer ? Moi ça me fait pas marrer. Mise
à part le fait que la Banque de France
table sur une croissance à 5 % parce que
il souhait que les Français mangur bas
de laine économisé pendant le le le
confinement.
Est-ce que vous pouvez leur expliquer le
goût du sang ?
Euh alors ça c'est effectivement c'est
la minute placement. c'est que quand je
dis que je suis économiste, les gens
croient que je suis un spécialiste de la
bourse et cetera et comme il y a
beaucoup de gens parce qu'en fait il y a
beaucoup de gens qui ont beaucoup
d'argent en France he c'est ça ça c'est
très intéressant quand vous discutez
avec les gens personne n'a d'argent mais
quand vous regardez les statistiques de
l'épargne qui est colossal en France il
y a évidemment beaucoup de gens qui ont
de l'argent
il y a 2000 milliards de C'est ça
tout le monde mais tout le monde tout le
monde veut tout le monde veut veut cher
en fait ce qui est drôle c'est que là
pour la crise he on estime que l'État a
mis à peu près 200 milliards d'euros de
dépenses euh pour les entreprises, le
chômage et cetera.
Et en fait, l'épargne individuelle a
augmenté du même montant. Donc en fait,
ça prouve qu'on a pas aidé les bonnes
personnes. C'est-à-dire qu'il y a des
gens he il y a beaucoup de gens en fait
de salariés dont le salaire a continué
comme avant, dont les dépenses ont
beaucoup moins on ont beaucoup baissé
parce qu'ils travaillent plus. Donc
toutes les dépenses liées au travail ont
disparu. En plus, évidemment, il y a
plein de dépenses qu'on peut plus faire.
On peut plus aller au ciné, au resto et
cetera. Et donc il y a une épargne très
importante en France. Et donc ça cette
question de l'épargne, elle est vraiment
intéressante parce que ça montre à
l'inverse de ce que vous dites que si on
prend le pays et pas l'État parce qu'en
France on a beaucoup de mal à distinguer
l'État et le pays. C'est
qu'effectivement l'État français
malheureusement est devenu pauvre
puisqu'il est tout le temps en déficit.
Mais le pays est extrêmement riche. Et
donc là, on a un problème en fait qui
est très classique, qui un des problèmes
classiques du capitalisme, c'est que
vous avez d'un côté des besoins à
satisfaire,
vous avez la possibilité financière de
les satisfaire. On a surtout maintenant
avec les taux d'intérêt qui sont à zéro
ou qui sont même négatifs, l'État
français a en fait un compte ouvert
quasiment illimité. Ce qui veut dire que
toutes les projections les plus
sympathiques qu'on peut faire sur la
transition écologique, sur la
construction de logement, sur la
réhabilitation des services publics, que
les commissariats,
voilà soient à peu près tiennent debout
et cetera, et bien tout ça tout ça
vraiment on peut le financer très
facilement.
D'accord. Et la boucherie qui nous
attend pas. Et la boucherie, c'est que
comme on va pas le faire effectivement,
on arrive au début.
Vous êtes très kinésien jusqu'au bout
des ongles.
Ouais, par de la boucherie.
Alors,
la boucherie éthique, forcément. Ouais,
la boucherie, ça. La boucherie, la
boucherie bio. Euh
moi, enfin au bon, il y a le il y a le
moment du Covid, mais c'est vrai
qu'au-delà de ça, on sait on sait tous
et là, vous avez raison, on sait que ce
qu'on a vécu dans nos familles, he c'est
nos parents, nos grands-parents,
l'extraordinaire augmentation du niveau
de vie qui a été connu ces dernières
décennies, on sait que c'est terminé. On
sait que cette période là est terminée
et c'est la raison pour laquelle j'ai
amené ce petit livre très important, les
limites à la croissance.
C'est un livre qui a été publié en 1972
qui est pas un livre d'économiste, c'est
un livre d'ingénieur des grosses têtes
du Massachusetts Institute of
Technology, du MIT et qui notamment a
été écrit dont l'autrice principale est
une femme, ce qui est quand même assez
rare surtout à l'époque. Donc c'est un
livre de 1972.
Et donc là, les grosses têtes du MIT,
c'est des ingénieurs. Ils font tourner
leur modèle et ils nous disent
l'augmentation disent deux choses. Il
l'augmentation de la population mondiale
et l'augmentation de la richesse
mondiale ne sont pas soutenables. En
fait, ils prédisent l'avenir et on sait
aujourd'hui que leurs prédictions sont
incroyablement justes. leur prédiction
sur l'augmentation de la population
mondiale, leur prédiction sur
l'augmentation
de la consommation alimentaire mondiale,
sur la baisse des ressources sont
incroyablement justes. C'est-à-dire que
là, ces grosses têtes, ils prédisent
l'avenir et leur bouquet un succès
phénoménal. en 1972. Il est vendu à des
millions d'exemplaires. Il est traduit
dans 30 langues. En France, on le
connaît sous le nom de rapport pour le
club de Rome parce qu'effectivement, ils
sont financés par le club de Rome et
notamment par Volkswagen en Allemagne à
l'époque. Donc ils savent, ils prédisent
l'avenir. Mais on a un petit souci,
c'est qu'en 1973, il y a la crise de 73.
Et donc le premier déjà à l'époque le
souci des gouvernements c'est les
déficits, c'est l'inflation, c'est le
chômage. Et donc cette mine de
connaissance, le livre le plus important
qui a été écrit dans le monde ces
dernières décennies, ce livre-là, il n'a
pas euh il n'a pas de postérité, on
l'oublie. Et donc là, voilà, on revient
à ce problème de la connaissance. Mais
ce qu'on sait déjà, par exemple, ils le
disent juste dans l'introduction. Ça
serait vraiment chouette que l'éditeur
mettent l'introduction en libre accès.
Ils disent eux ils savent donc ils ont
fait plusieurs éditions. Donc là c'est
la la dernière édition du début de 2005.
Ils disent "Nous, on sait depuis le
début de des années 90 qu'on est en
surchauffe, qu'on est en surexploitation
des ressources mondiales. Et donc ça
c'est absolument dramatique.
C'est-à-dire qu'on sait que d'un point
de vue matériel, en moyenne nous tous,
les Français, les habitants de la
planète, notre situation va se dégrader
irrémédiablement au cours des années qui
viennent, au cours des décennies qui
viennent.
Comparé à la crise de 2008, ça va avoir
quel parfum ?
Et bien moi ce que ce que je moi ce qui
m'inquiète beaucoup c'est la dynamique
politique.
La
dynamique et politique.
Non mais c'est-à-dire que je vois euh
par exemple quand on voit dans les
enquêtes d'opinion, on voit beaucoup
monter l'idée que par exemple les
chômeurs seraient désassistés,
que les aides sociales seraient trop
importantes. Et comme j'ai vécu aux
États-Unis en fait, j'ai un peu
l'impression si vous voulez ça être très
très prenent de dire ça, ça va beaucoup
vous énerver. où aux États-Unis.
J'ai vécu à Boston pendant 2 ans et en
fait, j'ai un peu l'impression de
revenir du futur. C'est-à-dire que nous
en France, on aime beaucoup se moquer de
ces débiles d'Américains, mais en fait
quand on regarde ce qui se passe aux
États-Unis, c'est très très souvent un
très bon prédicteur de l'avenir.
Boston n'est pas les États-Unis, hein.
Boston, ça n'est pas les États-Unis.
Non, non, exactement. Ça n'est pas du
tout les États-Unis. Tout à fait. Toute
façon, les États-Unis, même ça n'existe
pas parce que c'est un pays qui est
tellement divers. Mais bref,
ce qu'on oublie, c'est que les pays
qu'on qualifie d'ultralibéraux
aujourd'hui comme les États-Unis ou le
Royaume-Uni sont des pays qui sont allés
beaucoup plus loin que nous dans
l'intervention publique. En Angleterre,
par exemple, en Angleterre après la
Seconde Guerre mondiale, vous avez un
système de santé entièrement gratuit. Le
médecin est gratuit, les médicaments
sont gratuits, les médecins sont
fonctionnaires. Ça n'a jamais existé en
France.
Déjà quand j'allais en Angleterre dans
les années 90, vous aviez des gens qui
mouraient faute de soin parce que les
fils d'attente étaient trop longues à
l'hôpital britannique. À l'époque en
France, on se moquait des anglais. En
2000, l'Organisation mondiale de la
santé classe la France meilleur système
de santé au monde. On y est allé là sur
les Cocorico, la Marseillaise et cetera.
On était les plus forts.
Les Américains, renseignez-vous sur le
New Deal. Le New Deal de Roosevelt,
c'est une intervention publique sans
équivalent dans le monde. Roosevelt va
même financer des artistes. Il est
tellement intelligent, il comprend
tellement ce qui se passe au début des
années 30
qui va même filer de la tune à des
articles comme par exemple Jackson
Polock qui va commencer à travailler
dans ces années-là parce que justement
Roosevelt contrairement exactement à
l'opposé de ce que fait Macron
aujourd'hui Roosevelt il sait que si les
artistes
restent au chômage pendant des années
bah ils peuvent pas continuer dans leur
métier et qu' vont donc abandonner leur
vocation et et donc ça sera triste. Et
donc il déverse des tonnes et des tonnes
de d'argent comme ça. Il crée un système
de retraite publique qui est absolument
fantastique. Contrairement à ce que les
gens croient, il y a un gros système de
retraite publique aux États-Unis. Bref,
basé sur des fonds
où est-ce qu'on en est
qui sont d'ailleurs très exposés à
certains risques.
Non, non, non, pas enfin bon pas la
retraite publique mais bon. Et
aujourd'hui, aujourd'hui quelle est la
situation en Angleterre ? C'est
quoi vos sources sur la retraite
publique aux États-Unis ?
Quel est Je pourrais vous les donner
après.
Non non, maintenant c'est bien.
Quelle est la situation en Angleterre,
aux États-Unis ? pas
Non mais il y a pas de Non non mais
c'est financé c'est c'est le même si
c'est la retraite par répartition c'est
comme en France vous payez ce qu'on
appelle le pay as youugo system
c'est-à-dire que eux nous c'est les
cotisations sociales eux c'est un impôt
qui est payé par les gens du qui
travaillent tous les mois et qui est
versé au retraité tous les mois il y a
aucune espèce de justement il y a aucun
placement justement c'est ça le côté
génal du système. Bref, aux États-Unis,
en Angleterre aujourd'hui,
chose que les Français ne comprennent
pas, même s'ils croient qu'ils
comprennent, les gens savent que tout
est payant.
Ils savent que c'est chacun pour soi.
Ils savent que l'éducation c'est payant,
que la santé c'est payant, que la
retraite c'est des placements privés.
Ils savent qu'ils ont rien à attendre de
personne. C'est le chacun pour soi.
C'est la loi de la jungle. Et donc moi,
c'est ça ma réponse à ce que vous dites,
c'est qu'effectivement la récession
actuelle qui est énorme va aggraver ça
et que donc on va avoir un système
terrible comme en Angleterre, comme aux
États-Unis où y compris les plus pauvres
de France vont refuser les politiques
dont il bénéficieraient. Parce que quand
vous pensez que c'est chacun pour soi,
quand vous devez payer l'école privée de
votre gamine, bah vous voulez plus payer
d'impôts puisque vous bénéficiez pas des
impôts. D'accord ? Et donc qu'est-ce qui
s'est passé en Angleterre, aux
États-Unis ? L'exemple typique c'est
Trump, c'est que vous avez des
catégories populaires qui votent
littéralement contre leur intérêt qui
votent et c'est c'est marrant parce que
Thomas Piquetti expliquait déjà ça dans
sa thèse qu'il a soutenu parce que c'est
un génie à 21 ans en 1994 dans la thèse
de Thomas Piquetti, il y a déjà un petit
modèle où il nous dit supposons qu'une
taxation sur l'héritage comment vous
votez les gens c'est une question
aujourd'hui les patrimoines en France
sont extrêmement élevés l'efficacité
économique voudrait qu'on taxe
élevé.
Qu'est-ce que vous appelez élevé ? Bah,
on est euh on est un des pays où le le
patrimoine donc le patrimoine, les
actions, les obligations, les placements
financiers, les logements, les terrains,
les entreprises, il y a une richesse
considérable en France. Bon bah là,
supposons supposons juste pour la
blague, il y a un candidat pour 2022 qui
suppose qui propose d'augmenter la
taxation sur l'héritage.
Tout le monde va être contre. Alors que
ce qui est très marrant, c'est que si
vous êtes un économiste libéral, ce qui
est un terme je pense très problématique
parce que les économistes libéraux en
fait sont pour la privatisation et la
privatisation c'est le contraire de la
liberté. Justement ce qu'expliquait bien
Bernard Maris c'est que qu'est-ce que
c'est la liberté concrètement en dehors
des grands débats philosophiques ? La
liberté, c'est l'éducation gratuite,
c'est la santé gratuite. La sécurité
sociale, c'est la liberté. Regardez tous
les retraités en France aujourd'hui qui
sont en bonne santé, qui ont une bonne
retraite, regardez comme ils sont
libres. Ils le disent tous. Ils sont
libérés du travail, ils ont encore des
années, ils sont en bonne santé, ils
peuvent faire plein de trucs. Ça c'est
la liberté. Et ben justement les gens
qui se disent libéraux, ils sont contre
ça. Ils veulent en permanence tout
privatiser. Et privatiser comme on a pas
arrêté de le faire. C'est aussi un bon
c'est aussi les retraités, vous parlez
des retraités en bonne santé, c'est
aussi un bon cheptel électoral pour le
politique.
Alors, c'est sûr que les les retraités,
c'est les c'est effectivement les gens
qui qui votent le plus. Ça, c'est vrai
qu'on a il y a un petit problème, c'est
que le
bon qui est commun à toutes les
démocraties occidentales, he c'est que
les les gens qui ont le plus besoin de
la politique, c'estàdire les gens qui
sont pas nés dans le bon milieu social,
qui ont pas eu de chance, les gens qui
ont vraiment besoin qu'on s'occupe d'eux
parce que des gens comme moi en fait,
moi la politique, j'en ai pas besoin.
Les décisions politiques, ça m'affecte
pas. Enfin, faudrait vraiment, je vois
pas quelle décision pour être prise qui
est vraiment une importance dans ma vie.
Moi ma vie ça va très bien. Mais les
gens qui ont besoin de la politique mais
justement c'est mes étudiants au
chômage, c'est les patrons dont la boîte
fait faillite, c'est tous les
agriculteurs qui s'en sortent pas. C'est
ces gens-là qui ont besoin de la
politique. Et ben quand on regarde et
c'est très impressionnant au cours des
dernières décennies, ce sont les
catégories les plus défavorisées qui
votent le moins mais de façon très très
nette. Et en plus quand elle vote, elle
vote de façon assez logique pour des
partis qui ne sont pas élus et donc en
fait leur voix ne compte pas. Et
évidemment les stratèges des partis
politiques, on le voit très bien
actuellement se mettre en place pour la
campagne présidentielle, le savent tout
ça. Et on voit euh l'évolution la plus
nette de ce point de vue-là, c'est le
Parti socialiste, hein. C'est que le
Parti socialiste,
le quoi ? Le Parti socialiste ne fait
même plus semblant ne fait même plus
semblant de s'adresser aux catégories,
aux ouvriers, aux employés qui
constituent quand même la moitié de la
population française. Là, le petit jeu
que je vous donne,
il y a beaucoup d'employés, du moins il
y a beaucoup de de gens au Parti
socialistes qui sont issus du bas, j'ai
pas l'impression. Déjà, je pense qu'il y
a pas beaucoup de gens au Parti
socialiste tout court, mais le petit le
petit
question initiale par rapport à la
question de la récession de 2008, ça va
ça va avoir quel goût notre récession de
C'est très largement pire. Pardon ? Non,
proportion.
Bah en fait la alors mince, attendez, la
récession de 2000 bits en France euh
ça dû être mais bon, j'ai pas visiser
les chiffres avant de venir mais je
pense que la récession de 2008 en France
ça dû c'est quelques pourc de PIB parce
qu'en fait c'est la crise de 2008 c'est
une crise financière et là il se passe
quelque chose d'assez intéressant c'est
que on a du on a on a de la chance à
l'époque c'est que le monsieur qui
dirige la banque centrale des États-Unis
s'appelle Ben Bernanke, c'est un
universitaire et c'est un spécialiste de
la crise des années 30. Et donc
qu'est-ce qu'il sait Ben Mernanke ? Il
sait qu'il ne faut pas si on veut sauver
la démocratie,
on n'est pas obligé de vouloir mais si
on veut
gagner du temps.
Non non voilà. Oui, on pourrait dire ça.
Si on veut gagner du temps, il faut
surtout ne pas laisser faire faillite
les banques. Et donc c'est à ce
moment-là on a une chance folle. Et donc
alors ce qui est bien c'est qu'il sauve
toutes les banques de la planète et donc
toutes les banques centrales de la
planète font comme lui. L'énorme erreur
politique qu'ils font qui sera aussi
l'énorme erreur d'Obama parce que les
gens ont oublié pourquoi est-ce que
Trump arrive au pouvoir à cause de
Barack Obama. Parce que Barack Obama il
fait des très beaux discours sur
je sais pas le vivre ensemble, la
tolérance et tout. Mais Barack Obama
vous remarquerez qu'il s'est jamais
adressé aux ouvriers américains. Il les
intéressait pas.
Il a rien fait pour augmenter le salaire
minimum aux États-Unis. Il a rien fait
pour restaurer les services publics aux
États-Unis. Et quand on sauve les
banques à l'époque, on fait l'erreur
incroyable sur le plan politique. Les
mecs, ils sont à genoux. Les mecs de
Wall Street qui sont à genoux comme
jamais depuis 1929. Et là, c'est pas une
exagération. Donc, on peut leur faire ce
qu'on veut. Et qu'est-ce qu'on leur fait
? Rien.
On les sort de l'eau, on les essort.
Non, non, on les non, on les essort pas
du tout.
Non, non, on les sèche.
Oui, voilà. Ça, on les sort de l'eau et
on leur demande rien. C'est-à-dire qu'on
leur demande pas d'allérer de diminuer
leur rémunération extravagante. On leur
donne aucune espèce de limitation dans
ou l'orientation des prêts pour faire
des prêts qu' aillent un tout petit peu
plus vers les PME, un petit peu vers
l'écologie, enfin des trucs qui jusqu'
un minimum de sens. On leur demande de
rien. Et là, effectivement, votre
question est très bonne, c'est qu'à ce
moment-là, pour plein de gens à
commencer aux États-Unis, mais aussi en
Europe, les gens deviennent dingues.
Regardez le Brexit, par exemple.
Pourquoi est-ce qu'autant de gens ont
voté pour le Brexit ? Parce que
contrairement à ce qui s'est passé en
France, il faut le dire très clairement,
en France, le sauvetage des banques n'a
rien coûté. N'a rien coûté et a même
rapporté à l'État français dans le cas
de la France. Mais au Royaume-Uni, c'est
pas du tout le cas. Une des une des plus
grandes failliques, c'est la Royal Bank
of la Royal Bank of Scotland qui fait
faillite à l'époque. Elle fait vraiment
faillite. Et donc là, l'État anglais et
c'est encore pire en Irlande va dépenser
des dizaines de milliards. Et ça, les
électeurs ils s'en souviennent. Et quand
effectivement on va leur demander de
voter sur une autre question qui va être
le Brexit, eux ils vont faire le lien en
disant pourquoi est-ce que moi on me
demande toujours de faire des efforts ?
Pourquoi est-ce que moi je dois toujours
être compétitif ? Parce que c'est le
discours qu'on sert à ces populations
comme partout. Qu'est-ce qui se passe
dans tous les pays du monde ? vous dit
"Ah ben les amis, on peut pas augmenter
vos salaires parce que sinon vous allez
pas être compétitif par rapport à
l'Italie, le Portugal, l'Allemagne, la
Chine, les États-Unis, dans tous les
pays, les dirigeants" et c'est ça qui
est prodigieux, dans tous les pays, les
dirigeants nous disent que le chômage
c'est de notre faute, que les problèmes
économiques du pays, c'est de notre
faute parce qu'on est trop payé, parce
qu'on n pas assez productif. C'est
prodigieux que vous avez des
gouvernements, vous pouvez reprendre les
discours, c'est dit textaux, vous avez
des gouvernements qui mettent en
permanence en accusation leur
population. C'est ça le drame
démocratique. Et qui par contre vont
sauver hein les petits amis de la
société générale pour qui tout va bien,
pour qui s'est rien passé. Mais quand
vous donnez l'occasion aux gens de voter
pour de vrai et les référendums sur
l'Union européenne sont très nets
là-dessus, c'est pour ça qu'il y en a eu
très très peu. Quand vous regardiez les
référendums sur l'Union européenne, les
gens quasiment toujours voté non hein.
En France, c'est passé très juste à
Mastricht. En Irlande, ils avaient voté
non. On a refait voter pour qu'il vote
oui. Pareil au Pays-Bas et cetera. Quand
vous donnez l'occasion aux gens de
s'exprimer, ils comprennent ce qui se
passe. Mais c'est très facile qu'ils
comprennent ce qui se passe puisqu'on
leur dit et en France en particulier,
même lorsque la gauche a gouverné, quand
on nous parlait de la modération
salariale qui a été mise en place par
Jacques de l'or en 1983, qu'est-ce que
c'est la modération salariale ? C'est
exactement dire ça. C'est de dire si
vous voulez un emploi, il faut être
compétitif. Si vous voulez être
compétitif, il faut baisser vos
salaires. Et on a eu cette période
extraordinaire dans les années 90 où
vous aviez une majorité, si je prends
les termes officiels, social-démocrate
en Europe. Vous aviez Tony Blair en
Angleterre, vous avez Gerard Schroder en
Allemagne, Lionel Jospin en France.
Qu'est-ce que fait par exemple Gerard
Schoder ? Il met en place ce qu'il
appelle l'agenda 2010. C'est la plus
grande contre-réforme sociale européenne
depuis Margaret Satcher. Aujourd'hui en
Allemagne, vous avez des millions de
gens qui sont pauvres. Vous avez des
millions de retraités qui doivent
recommencer à travailler parce qu'ils
ont pas assez à bouffer. Parce qu'il a
réduit très fortement les allocations
chômage. Parce qu'il a réduit très
fortement les retraites.
Ce qui va se passer chez nous.
Oui, c'est ce qui en fait ce qui a déjà
très largement commencé en France aussi.
Mais Gerard Schroder, c'est quelqu'un
qui se présentait comme
social-démocrate. Aujourd'hui, c'est
quelqu'un qui travaille pour Poutine et
cetera. C'est la c'est c'est la classe
totale. Donc cet homme-là, Gerard
Schroder, ce que pourquoi j'insiste
là-dessus, c'est que ces réformes sont
passées d'autant plus facilement qu'il
se présentaient comme social-démocrate.
Il aurait dit "Je suis un affreme mec de
droite, je suis là pour vous
écrabouiller." Il y aurait eu beaucoup
plus de résistance.
Un peu comme les socialistes, non ?
Alors, c'est un petit peu comme les
socialistes français. Et par rapport à
ce que vous disiez effectivement par
exemple reprend l'assurance chômage, il
faut savoir qu'en France aujourd'hui il
y a nettement moins de la moitié d'un
chômeur sur deux qui touche une
allocation chômage. Nettement moins de
la moitié. Et euh on parle souvent du
déficit de l'assurance chômage.
Évidemment que l'assurance chômage en
déficit cette année, c'est tout à fait
normal. Mais le gouvernement euh avait
se rappel je peux vous rappeler de la
fameuse phrase de Muriel Penicou hein
qui euh qui avait vendu sa réforme de
l'assurance chômage en disant c'est une
réforme qui va accroître la précarité
hein parce que son cerveau était occupé
à penser il faut pas que je le dise il
faut pas que je le dise et donc elle a
dit ma réforme va accroître la précarité
c'est un des une des rares phrases
sincères qui a été dites par ce
gouvernement depuis le début du
quinquena
et elle menait sa réforme au nom du
déficit de l'assurance chômage. Bon, si
les mots ont un sens, qu'est-ce que
c'est l'assurance chômage ? C'est une
assurance qui est payée par nous tous
quand on travaille, qui est pris sur
notre salaire sous forme de cotisation
sociale et en contrepartie, on verse des
allocations chômage aux gens qui sont au
chômage. Ça c'est l'assurance comme les
assurances privées pour la bagnole ou le
logement. Quand vous faites la
comparaison entre les deux et ben en
fait le régime il est équilibré parce
que justement il y a eu tellement de
réforme ces dernières années qu'on a
tellement baisser les allocations
chômage que le régime il est équilibré.
Et alors par contre effectivement si
vous cherchez il y a un déficit de
l'assurance chômage. Et d'où il vient ?
Il vient de ce que l'État parce qu'en
fait les gens ne connaissent pas la
différence entre l'État et la sécurité
sociale et ça c'est quand même un très
gros problème. L'État impose à
l'assurance chômage de financer Pôle
Emploi mais Pôle Emploi c'est pas
l'assurance chômage, c'est le service
d'aide, vous voyez à la à l'emploi, à la
recherche de travail pour les chômeurs,
c'est autre chose. Donc encore une fois,
le régime d'assurance chômage hors
période évidemment de Covid, il est
équilibré et ça n'empêche pas les
gouvernements successifs de nous dire
depuis des années, il y a un énorme
déficit de l'assurance chômage. Et là
encore, on a à peu près mise à part par
exemple Christian Chavagneux alternative
économique, on a à peu près aucun
journaliste qui juste fait son travail
qui est d'expliquer que bah non, en
temps normal, encore une fois au Covid,
il n'y a pas de déficit de l'assurance
chômage. Même chose que j'avais
travaillé sur les retraites quand il y a
eu la réforme des retraites, vous
retrouvez très facilement. Il y a eu un
communiqué officiel du gouvernement
se réjouissant du fait que le régime
général des retraites était à
l'équilibre.
Il y a quasiment pas évidemment hors
Covid parce que les réformes précédentes
là aussi ont beaucoup réduit les
retraites. C'est ce que je disais sur
les retraités on sait qu'évidemment ça
n'est plus vrai pour nous. C'est-à-dire
que mes parents voilà c'est la bonne la
bonne coorte. c'est les gens
effectivement qui ont une retraite
élevée, mais on sait tous pour toutes
les raisons évidentes et notamment et là
le le Covid va avoir des effets retardés
terribles, c'est que tous les gens qui
vont être au chômage pendant 1 an, 2
ans, 3 ans et ben les 40 41 42 annuités,
ben juste ils les auront jamais. Et ça,
je trouve que la réforme des retraites,
c'est un des trucs les plus malins et
des trucs les pires, c'est qu'on vous
oblige à remplir une obligation que vous
maîtrisez pas. C'est qu'on vous dit bon
c'est vraiment comme vous signez un
contrat dont en plus le le l'État
s'autorise à modifier les termes en
cours de route ce que je trouve très
bizarre d'un point de vue juridique.
Bref, vous commencez votre carrière et
on vous dit si vous cotisez ça doit être
42 ans maintenant si vous codisez
pendant 42 ans, vous allez avoir la
retraite maximum en fonction de votre
salaire. OK, mais c'est pas vous qui
du du salaire du la fond de la sécurité
sociale.
Ouais, mais ça c'est pour les gens qui
sont bien payés, ça concerne très peu de
monde. Euh donc, mais voyez, on vous dit
il faut bosser pendant 42 ans, mais
c'est pas vous qui décidez hein. Il faut
savoir par exemple, on parle beaucoup
des entrepreneurs, des
auto-entrepreneurs, mais en France plus
de C'est c'est très étonnant même avec
les professions libérales, même avec les
agriculteurs, les commerçants, les
artisans, en France, plus de 90 % des
gens qui travaillent sont salariés. plus
de 90 % des gens sont salariés, donc
sils sont pas propriétaires de leur
emploi. Donc s'ils sont lourdés ou si
vous avez des problème de santé ou si ou
si ou si si vous avez pas les années de
cotis et que vous commencez à être vieux
et vous avez envie de sortir du truc,
votre retraite elle baisse très
fortement et ce qui est génial c'est que
personne l'a décidé. Voyez, vous pouvez
vous plaindre contre personne. Et quand
on regarde aujourd'hui avec
l'allongement de la durée des études,
vous finissez vos études à 20 ans, 21
ans, 22 ans, 23 ans, on rajoute 42 ans.
Ça veut dire que aujourd'hui, on sait
par exemple que pour les jeunes, l'âge
réel de la retraite, c'est au moins 65
ans si vous avez une carrière absolument
nickel, sans aucune interruption pendant
42 ans, ce qui n'est évidemment pas le
cas. euh des
67,
voilà, des catégories défavorisées parce
que par exemple autre chose, on donne
jamais euh on donne jamais le taux de
chômage par catégorie sociale, voyez, on
donne toujours un taux de chômage très
général mais en fait et même là aussi le
vocabulaire a évolué quand vous regardez
les actualités des années 60 70, vous
dites quand quand ils interrogent les
gens dans la rue, par exemple, vous avez
quelqu'un qui dit "Je suis électricien
au chômage." C'est que le gars il dit
"Je suis électricien
et là je suis au chômage. Je suis pas
chôur les gens c'est chômeur c'est pas
un métier voyez ça c'est une catégorie
statistique qui est imposée par le par
l'État par la statistique publique sur
les gens
c'est quoi c'est pour les faire
culpabiliser ?
Non mais c'est parce que le chômage est
tellement élevé depuis des décennies
qu'en fait on s'est habitué à définir
des gens en disant je suis chômeur comme
on dit comme on disait avec cette
expression atroce erémiste. Voyez on
devrait dire alors il y a des gens qui
font l'effort de le faire. On doit dire
personne par exemple à locataire du RSA
ou je sais pas personne sans abri où on
dit personne en situation de handicap.
Mais dire chômeur ou chômeuse on efface
la profession des gens. Et quels sont
les gens qui sont frappés par le chômage
? Évidemment, les gens qui sont issus
des catégories sociales les plus
défavorisées dont les parents avaient
pas les moyens de payer des études qui
ont les niveaux d'études les moins
élevés et qui donc sont le plus
concernés par les fermetures d'usine,
par les licenciements, par les carrières
achées. Donc ça c'est quand même assez
intéressant qu'une statistique qu'on
peut trouver très facilement pour le
coup sur le site de l'INC qui est de
regarder le taux de chômage par
catégorie sociale n'est jamais donné.
Vous voyez ?
On revient toujours à ce problème que
des choses quand même très simples, des
connaissances très basiques, on les a
pas. Alors par contre tout le monde a un
jugement surtout, mais on les a pas.
Moi, le truc auquel je pense très
souvent en ce moment, c'est de me dire
la création de la sécurité sociale.
Rendez-vous compte la création de la
sécurité sociale. Vous êtes dans un pays
en ruine. Dans un pays en ruine. Vous
avez encore un très grand nombre. Vous
coupez d'un coup là.
Ouais.
Là là on est dans un payur en une certes
mais on a une rente énergétique
disponible. On a accès à au au pétrole
pas cher, des choses comme ça.
Ouais
là c'est plus le cas.
Je vous je vous entendais de parler des
limites de la croissance.
Ouais. Pour un économiste, c'est en
général les économistes qu'on reçoit euh
il parlent pas du tout de consommation
énergétique. H
ils parlent de croissance, ils parlent
de croissance, ils parlent de récession
mais ils font pas les passerelles avec
les fondamentaux de soutenabilité d'une
économie.
Donc à chaque fois qu'on a été en
récession, on a toujours tapé dans les
réserves énergétiques pour ressortir de
ça au détriment de l'écologie. On est
d'accord ?
Ouais. Ah totalement. Totalement. Donc
là, je je vous dresse dans avec mes mots
un petit peu triviaux.
Ouais.
On va se prendre un [__] de mur dans
la tête. Oui. Oui.
Mais on n pas les capacités de retourner
chez mamie pour aller manger un peu de
gâteau dans le frigo. La métaphor avec
mamie et le gâteau, c'est les gisements
de pestro facilement accessible,
facilement exploitable et j'en passe des
meilleurs. Hm.
Donc quand je vous ai posé la question
sur le goût du sang de la récession
qu'on allait avoir
H
ben je pense que la la une des façons
d'aborder ça, c'est de se dire euh ça
dépasse totalement mes compétences, mais
je pense que finalement personne les a
vraiment.
Économiste donc c'est bon hein.
Oui, c'est ça. Non, mais c'est de se
dire euh bah en fait, faudrait revenir à
des vraies questions. Alors là, ça vous
fait rire mais tant pis. changer de
modèle, changer de paradigme,
non ? Mais c'est de dire tout simplement
en fait qu'est-ce qu'on veut faire de
nos vies, mais vraiment qu'est-ce qu'on
veut faire de notre vie ?
Est-ce que vous pensez que les gens sont
conscients qu'ils sont en vie ?
Mais moi, moi je moi je suis vraiment
alors là pour le coup certain que tout
le monde a compris ce qui se passe, mais
vraiment tout le monde. Sur le plan
écologique. Ça c'est
senti.
Ouais. Non mais non mais les gens je
veux dire là l'information est très
facilement disponible et on voit même
quand vous faites la queue à la
boulangerie tout ça on voit que dans
tous les milieux sociaux dans tous les
du pays il y a cette terreur écologique
et le problème tout ce qui manque c'est
rien du tout c'est d'avoir à un moment
les gens dont je parlais les fameux
journalistes du 20h les ministres et
cetera qui disent bah ouais bah oui
évidemment c'est la merde total et ben
ok et ben déjà on fait redescendre la
pression en disant mais évidemment que
c'est la merde totale.
D'autre part, on reste à notre place,
c'est-à-dire que le climat mondial, il
est hors de contrôle de tout le monde.
Et on sait justement, ils expliquent
très bien dans dans ce bouquin que on
est au début de phénomène cumulatif
qu'ils vont faire que s'accélérer. En
France aujourd'hui, tous les ans, il y a
des restrictions d'eau dans la majorité
des départements. Dans de nombreux
endroits en France, il y a des luttes
physiques politiques très fortes pour
l'eau. pour l'eau dans un pays tempéré.
Faites une petite recherche sur
internet.
Même en Guadeloupe.
Oui. Non mais mais je veux dire en
France voyez, on nous a tous appris à
l'école quand j'étais petit. C'est la
Guadeloupe
qu'on était ou Oui. qu'on était un
climat tempérade. C'est la France
pardon.
C'est ça. Toutes les prédictions des
climatologues nous disent qu'à la fin du
siècle on ne sera plus un pays tempéré.
On ne sera plus un pays tempéré. Il y
aura des restrictions d'eau généralisées
tout le temps dans la majorité du
territoire. Tout ça, on le sait avec
certitude et donc il faut simplement que
médiatiquement, politiquement, ce que
tout le monde sait, ça soit admis.
Alors, je je je vais lire un commentaire
qui est dans la section qui n'a rien à
faire là, mais c'est intéressant, un
commentaire de Jen Jiscan.
Ah,
je connais beaucoup de monde qui en ont
rien à battre.
Je d'ailleurs je passe un message. Merci
d'éviter vos commentaires ici. C'est que
les questions.
Donc c'est c'est vrai. C'est vrai. Il y
a beaucoup de personnes. C'est il s'en
aur juste rien à secouer.
Oui, c'est vrai. Oui, bien sûr. Mais
et puis puis il y a beaucoup d'escroc
aussi qui vraiment rien à secouer.
Oui, c'est vrai. Je veux dire, moi qui
suis dans les débats économiques et
politiques depuis toujours, ce qui
m'impressionne, c'est que autant mes
petits débats, mes petits combats de
gauche pour les services public et tout
ça,
j'ai jamais vu, si vous voulez une
question qui tarude autant de gens dans
la société de tout encore une fois
pardon, mais de toute classe d'âge, de
tout niveau social que la question
écologique. Enfin, c'est très
impressionnant. Je suis assez vieux pour
me souvenir de l'époque où on en parlait
pas du tout. J'ai eu zéro cours sur
l'écologie dans tout mon cursus. Vous
regardez le programme de MAFC, il y a
toujours pas de cursus sérieux sur
l'écologie. Ce que vous avez dit, c'est
très juste. La base des cours
aujourd'hui, mais pas à la fac, au
collège. Et même ce qui est bizarre,
c'est qu'on le fait à l'école primaire.
Ce qu'on devrait enseigner aujourd'hui
le plus, la première chose qu'on devrait
enseigner aux enfants de notre pays,
c'est le fonctionnement physique de la
planète. c'est de leur apprendre comment
fonctionne le monde, quels sont les
besoins, quelles sont les ressources,
quelles sont les pollutions. Et
effectivement, c'est terrible parce que
là, ça demanderait une honnêteté de la
part des gens qui font les programmes
qu'ils n'ont pas et une et un courage de
la part des enseignants qui là devrait
être soutenu pour le coup très fortement
par leur hiérarchie. c'est d'expliquer
effectivement ce qui est expliqué dans
ce bouquin là, que notre mode de
fonctionnement actuel est parfaitement
insoutenable, que c'est une certitude
scientifique, qu'il y a aucun débat
là-dessus et que donc nos enfants au
coup de leur vie vont voir arriver un
monde extrêmement différent de celui
dans lequel ils sont nés. C'est comme
ça. Est-ce qu'ils seront plus malheureux
ou moins malheureux ? J'en sais rien.
Est-ce que c'est même une question qui a
du sens ? C'est pas sûr, mais en tout
cas, il faut simplement leur expliquer
comment fonctionne le monde d'un point
de vue physique, d'un point de vue des
espèces, d'un point de vue du climat. On
parle, je pense beaucoup trop du climat.
Je pense qu'on n pas compris, même si
c'est lié évidemment au climat que le et
ça ça rejoint tout à fait votre truc sur
le goût du sang, que déjà dans beaucoup
d'endroits de la planète, on se bat pour
des ressources, on se bat pour la
flotte, on se bat pour la fou, pour la
bouffe et on va se battre pour ça aussi
en France très très rapidement. La
question principale aujourd'hui, c'est
celle de la ressource, de la ressource
énergétique, des ressources vitales.
C'est voilà, il y a juste pas assez de
production par rapport encore une fois
au nombre que nous sommes sur terre et à
la richesse que nous avons. C'est-à-dire
que nous tous là, on est en train de
consommer d'énergie, tout ça
parce que là là, on vient de faire le
constat que
on a une percass journalistique et
politique qui est l'équivalent d'un
canard sans tête.
On a des économistes et un corps
professoral pareil, un peu déconnecté de
la réalité.
On fait quoi ? On fait quoi là ? Les
élections arrivent, il faut aller voter,
il faut pas aller voter, on vote blanc,
on vote pas blanc
ou est-ce que simplement on rche chez
soi ?
Alors voilà, c'est ce que j'allais vous
dire déjà on peut lire des livres parce
qu'il y a des très bons livres. Par
exemple, il y a un de mes un de mes
professeurs qui est âgé maintenant qui
s'appelle Jean Gadray qui a écrit un
magnifique livre qui s'appelle Adieu à
la croissance. On explique très bien
tout ce que je viens de vous dire là.
Ça de renoncer à la croissance.
Non mais encore une fois, encore une
fois, c'est tabou dans les sphères
déconnecté mais dans la réalité. Surtout
qu'il faut, c'est très important surtout
dans un pays comme la France où la
population augmente. Là aussi le seul
chiffre qui compte c'est la croissance
par habitant. C'est le seul chiffre qui
compte et ce chiffre n'est jamais donné.
Donc déjà qu'on commence par donner la
croissance par habitant et on verra que
cette croissance par habitant en France
depuis des années, elle est zéro. Donc
déjà ça règle la question.
La la deuxième chose, par exemple, il y
a des il y a deux auteurs britanniques
que j'adore qui sont épidémiologistes et
qui s'appellent Richard Wilkinon et Kate
Picket.
C'est pas encore la dernière question.
Ouais. Ouais. Non mais dans tous les
bouquins sont traduits en français et
qui font le lien et c'est absolument
génial entre en fait les modèles
d'éducation dans l'enfance, la capacité
d'avoir des comportements coopératifs et
la solution aux problèmes économiques.
Et ce qui montre,
ça revient ça revient ma première
question sur notre système scolaire est
en train de sélectionner que les plus
toxiques.
Bon je comme vous avez bien compris,
j'ai pas répondre à cette question parce
que je je n'ai pas la réponse
parce que vous les sélectionnez
peut-être aussi. Non
non non, moi je non je sélectionne rien
du tout moi. Moi je enfin presque pas.
Vous donnez pas de notes ?
Non mais on peut donner une notes sans
sélectionner.
Pourquoi donner des notes ?
B pourquoi donner des notes ? Mais là où
je suis d'accord,
on donne des notes.
Non non mais tout à fait mais il y a
plein de de profs qui qui en donnent
pas. C'est marrant que vous racontiez ça
d'ailleurs euh là justement ma gamine me
racontait que encore aujourd'hui j'étais
consterné. Elle a une de ses profs vous
savez qui rend les notes en classant les
élèves.
C'est horrible.
C'est hallucinant qu'on en soit encore
là. Et
c'est hallucinant. Et quand j'ai
enseigné aux États-Unis, ça a été ma
première erreur. C'était génial. J'étais
chargé de TD et donc il y avait des
interroos très souvent et je rends la
première interro et donc je distribue
les copies et je vois qu'il y a un gros
malaise dans la salle et je comprends
pas ce qui se passe et après il y a un
élève qui vient m'expliquer c'est que je
leur avais rendu leur copie avec la note
sur la première page et donc les autres
pouvaient connaître leurs notes et aux
États-Unis comme ils protègent beaucoup
mieux l'amour propre des enfants que
nous et bien c'est vrai que c'est vrai
que votre note ça concerne que vous
c'est une information privée et donc les
profs mettent la note sur la 2è page.
C'estd que quand vous rendez la copie
sur la première page, il n'y a rien et
la note et les commentaires sont sur la
deuxième page. Et ben ce simple respect
des élèves, des enfants en France, on ne
l'a pas. Et là où je suis d'accord avec
vous, c'est que l'éducation nationale
est le principal problème du pays. C'est
le principal problème du
Je pose la question.
Non, non, mais je Non, oui, pardon. En
tout cas, moi je vous le dis
effectivement. Euh autant il y a
énormément de choses qui disent
fonctionnent en France. Et alors là pour
le coup, je n'ai aucun espoir parce
queentre le corporatisme des
enseignants, entre ce que je vais dire
là extrêmement violent, mais c'est la
réalité, euh le aujourd'hui être prof en
collège, c'est un boulot de merde.
D'accord ? C'est un boulot de merde.
C'estàd que
c'est la c'est ça doit être vraiment la
pire
c'est la base c'est la base de la
société. C'est la base de la société
mais tous les gouvernements le savent et
il y a aucun ministre aujourd'hui qui
souhaite que sa fille ou son fils se
retrouve prof de math en collège.
C'est l'équivalent de de flic dans le
93, c'est ça ? Oui. Ouais. Pas tout à
fait, mais ça s'en rapproche. Euh
aujourd'hui dans quatre profs en
collège, c'est 1600 € par mois. Alors le
flic il est encore en 93, il est payé
plus cher quand même.
Donc personne dans les catégories
favorisées, personne ne souhaite que ses
enfants soient profs en collège. Et dans
ces catégories favorisées, personne ne
se dit que ça c'est un énorme problème.
C'est-à-dire qu'aujourd'hui, c'est là
que le raisonnement de l'économiste
basique est quand même utile. Quand vous
avez un boulot qui est très dur et qui
est mal payé, bah qu'est-ce qui se passe
? Bah vous recrutez pas les meilleurs
parce que les meilleurs ils font autre
chose. Quand vous êtes bon en maths
aujourd'hui, vous allez pas faire prof
de math en collège quand vous avez tout
les boulot qui vous attendent dans
l'informatique.
Vous rejoignez vous rejoignez Laurent
Alexandre.
Oh j' je suis vraiment pas trop fan de
Laurent Alexandre mais
non mais vous le rejoignez sur sur ça
c'està dire qu'il ou pas le rejoindre
lui par en il faut envoyer des
polytechniciens au collège pour
enseigner les maths.
Ah non ça c'est complètement débile mon
ami. Non non non non. Ce qui non mais ce
qui enfin en fait ce qui est marrant
c'est que je pense pour le coup que
si on sortait de la folie du système de
l'éducation nationale, je trouve
vraiment mais c'est peut-être parce que
j'arrivais à un âge dans ma profession,
je trouve qu'enseigner cette
47 ans, parler comme si vous en aviez 95
au seuil de la mort.
C'est ça. Non mais
ça veut dire quoi ? C'est ça
? Écoutez, bah c'est ça. J'ai 95 ans en
fait. Je trouve qu'enseigner, c'est très
facile. Enseigner, c'est très facile à
partir du moment où vous vous posez
cette question simple qui de dire
pourquoi je suis là ? Pourquoi les
gamins sont là ? Et qu'est-ce qu'on fait
ensemble ? Et cette question là dans le
système de l'éducation nationale, vous
avez pas le droit de vous la poser parce
que vous avez les programmes. Parce que
vous avez les programmes, parce que à la
minute près, vous avez pas la liberté de
choisir ce que vous allez faire. On a
tous vécu ça. Le premier cours,
combien d'années on a vécu ça au collège
au lycée ? Le premier cours, le prof qui
nous dit "Ah, j'ai pas le temps de
répondre à votre question à cause du
programme, le premier cours."
Comment une profession quand même
éduquée comme celle des enseignants et
là je sais que je vais pas me faire des
amis a accepté de se faire soumettre à
ce point-là. Il se trouve que par
hasard, j'ai participé à une réunion au
ministère de l'éducation nationale sur
les programmes.
En quelle année ?
Euh c'était l'année dernière ou il y a 2
ans. Sur les programmes en sciences
économiques et sociales.
Et là, j'ai découvert
Vous étiez la caution de gauche ?
Euh, ouais, pas loin. Et alors là, j'ai
tout découvert et j'ai comme la même
chose sur BFM. Non,
j'étais c'était consterné.
Vous êtes la conscient de gauche quand
vous êtes sur BFM ? Non.
Moi, je crois que BFM ils ont enfin ils
ont pas besoin de caution. Enfin, ils
font ce qu'ils veulent. Mais pense que
paye quand vous allez là-bas.
Euh bah quand j'étais quand j'étais au
les grandes gueules, c'est payé. Oui.
C'est c'est payé combien ?
C'est payé euh attendez, les grandes
gueules, je crois que c'est c'est payé
400 € je crois
l'émission.
Ouais.
Brut ou net ?
Non, brute là. Brut par contre.
Euh et donc quand j'étais au ministère,
donc je cette réunion pour les
programmes de sciences économiques et
sociales et là je découvre ce que ce que
j'ignorais bêtement que la réunion est
présidée par un prof de fac.
Donc quelqu'un qui ne veut surtout pas
être prof au collège au lycée qui
méprise les profs de collège et le
lycée.
Je suis puté. Ah non, parce que je peux
non, vraiment c'est ce que j'ai vécu,
c'est que ça respirait, ça sointait la
prétention de l'universitaire.
Le mec était même prof au collège de
France, son nom m'échappe mais non mais
c'est un sociologue de la culture. Et
d'ailleurs, c'est très marrant parce que
comme vous, il m'a parlé de BFM, ce qui
était complètement déplacé par rapport à
la situation. Et donc, je rentre dans la
réunion, on est une vingtaine, je
connais pas les gens.
C'était un petit pic gratuit hein.
Ouais. Et là, il y a des profs ou il y a
des profs du secondaire et je vois déjà
chercher le mien. les profs du
secondaire qui rentrent et ils sont là
pour écouter l'oracle qui va alors que
lui il en a rien à [__] ça ça ne
l'affecte rien dans sa vie qui va leur
dire ce qu'ils vont devoir faire avec
leurs élèves toute la [__] de journée
toute la [__] d'année et ils acceptent
ça
la sainte journée s'il vous plaît
la sainte journée et alors là déjà je
suis sidéré bon et puis moi j'essaie de
lui faire comprendre qu'effectivement ça
serait donc il y a eu des réformes de
ces programmes. Il se trouve qu'avec
d'autres collègues, on s'est battu
pendant des années contre les reculs
très importants qui ont eu dans les
programmes. Parce qu'il faut savoir que
dans la grande nullité de l'éducation
nationale, il y avait une exception
remarquable qui était les sciences
économiques et sociales parce que
c'était le seul enseignement qui n'était
pas disciplinaire. Qui n'était pas
disciplinaire. C'est-à-dire que lorsque
les sciences économiques et sociales
sont crées à la fin des années 60, au
début des années 70 en France, on a là
pour le coup un des trucs relativement
unique au monde. On a des gens qui se
disent, il y a des choses qui existent
dans la réalité, il y a des entreprises,
il y a des familles. Et en fait, nous on
va enseigner ces objets de la réalité
aux élèves en allant puiser dans les
sens, en allant puiser en sociologie, en
allant puiser en économie, en s'appuyant
sur les articles de presse, en
s'appuyant sur des documentaires, en
s'appuyant beaucoup sur des documents,
on va mettre les lycéens face à la
réalité et on va leur montrer comment
les chercheurs en sciences sociales
analysent la réalité. Et donc les vrais
sociologues pénibles, les vrais
économistes pénibles ont toujours
détesté mépriser les sciences
économiques et social parce que c'était
de l'empirie, parce que c'était pas
nickel d'un point de vue théorique,
parce que il y avait des points de vues
différents qui s'y exprimaient. C'était
un enseignement fabuleux. Et ben cet
ennement fabuleux, il a été brisé par
les ministères successifs et aujourd'hui
il a été réduit et en fait il a été
calqué sur le très mauvais enseignement
de l'économie à la fac avec l'idée de
dire évidemment c'est pas dit comme ça
officiellement puisque ce qu'on fait à
la fac est complètement débile. J'ai
encore vu un témoignage d'une étudiante
ces derniers jours lessiv par ses années
de fac à la Sorbonne où elle a fait que
des maths, elle connaît rien de la
réalité. Donc puisque l'enseignement de
l'économie est pathétique, nul à la fac,
et ben on va calquer l'enseignement du
secondaire sur celui de la fac pour que
les lycéens qui avaient le droit de
s'exprimer, qui avaient le droit de
réfléchir par eux-mêmes dans ces cours
très innovants de sciences économiques
et sociales, on va bien les lobotomiser
pour qu'ils soient prêts pour la fac. Et
moi ça, je l'ai vécu comme tous les
enseignants. Quand j'ai commencé à
enseigner à la fac de Nanter au début de
ma thèse, je faisais mes TD d'économie
sur lequel j'avais le programme
justement et on avait des centaines
d'étudiants. Il fallait nous tous que
chargé de TD, on avance au même rythme
pour amener les étudiants aux interro et
cetera. Donc l'opposé total de ce que
doit être l'université, un espèce de
bâchautage débile et je faisais faire
exercice de math sur exercice de math
complètement inintéressant aux
étudiants. Et là, j'avais des bons
étudiants qui arrivaient en première
année de science Écho à Nanterre,
soit-disant la fac, soit-disant la
facuche de gauche. Donc là, on est en
1999,
qui avait adoré l'économie au lycée, qui
avait eu des super profs de sciences
économiques et sociales, qui avait
commencé à lire Kanes, qui avait
commencé à lire Smith
et Aek,
non ? et Yay mais bien sûr qui avait lu
les grands auteurs et là ils se
retrouvaient en fac d'co, il pensaiit
qu'ils allaient poursuivre dans cette
discipline qu'ils aimaient et il faisait
des petits exercices de math
complètement débiles et je les voyais
dépérir semaine après semaine et j'avais
honte de ce que je leur faisais et donc
j'essayais de terminer les exercices le
plus vite possible mais le problème
c'est qu'il y en avait beaucoup qui
étaient nuls en maths et donc je pouvais
pas aller trop vite non plus et
j'essayais de gratter 5 ou 10 minutes à
la fin du TD pour leur parler de ce qui
se passait vie
dans la vraie vie et à l'époque en fait
il y avait cette magnifique déflation
japonaise qui en plus correspondait
totalement au programme du cours puisque
c'était un programme de macroéconomie et
pour les experts on faisait le modèle
ISLM et justement il y a cette fameuse
trap à liquidité dans laquelle est
l'économie japonaise enfin était
l'économie japonaise à l'époque et dans
laquelle elle est restée pendant 20 ans.
Bon, c'est un de nos truc qu'on aime
beaucoup enseigner dans les bons cours
d'économie. Et donc je lisais dans la
presse tous les jours un truc
passionnant, fondamental euh sur
lesquels s'exprimaient les économistes
comme Paul Krugman à l'époque qui
correspondait totalement au programme du
cours mais que je ne pouvais
physiquement pas enseigner à mes
étudiants parce que euh donc toujours
pour les experts, je devais résoudre
toutes les semaines un système de deux
équations à deux inconnus, ce qui
n'avait aucun intérêt sur le plan
mathématique, ce qui était beaucoup trop
facile pour les bons étudiants, donc il
s'ennuyait, mais qui était aussi
beaucoup trop difficile pour les mauvais
étudiants. Donc je pouvais leur
expliquer dans tout
pas mauvais peut-être différent.
Oui. Non pardon. Non non mais non
carrément mais je veux dire juste qu'
avait pas le niveau en math et et ce qui
est prodigieux voilà donc c'est tout le
monde s'ennuyait je m'ennuyais. C'était
trop facile pour certains, trop dur pour
d'autres et en tout cas c'était
inintéressant pour tout le monde. Et
effectivement encore aujourd'hui
l'enseignement de l'économie est bourré
de math. Mais ce qu'il faut bien
comprendre c'est que les gens croient
qu'on fait des calculs en fac
d'économie. Ça fait pas des calculs,
c'est pas des statistiques justement ce
que vous disiez sur calculer, voyez, la
prochaine récession, ce qui serait un
peu débile dans le cas actuel mais qui
aurait du sens en temps normal. C'est
des modèles avec des lettres. C'est des
modèles avec des lettres, c'est-à-dire
que c'est de l'algèbre, c'est-à-dire
qu'on résout des modèles totalement
irréels et assumés comme tels
et déshumanisés
et totalement déshumanisé et assumé
comme tel pendant tout le cursus. Et
plus vous allez vers les faces
prestigieuses, plus c'est le cas. Mais
ça c'est qu'en France. Quand j'ai
enseigné aux États-Unis, le prof pour
lequel j'enseignais, c'est le mec qui a
écrit les manuels les plus vendus au
monde, traduit dans tous les pays du
monde. Il s'appelle Grégory Mancu. Vous
avez tous ces manuels, il en a fait
plein plein plein. Enfin, c'est pas lui
qui les écrit évidemment. Vous les avez
tous en français. Bon ben Grégory Mancu,
le cours pour lequel j'ai enseigné pour
lui, donc c'était Harvard à l'époque,
c'était le plus grand cours d'Harvard.
On avait 800 étudiants inscrits, on
était une quarantaine de chargés de TD.
Et Grégory Mancu, lui, ce que j'aimais
chez lui, c'est que c'est un mec
cohérent, c'est-à-dire que c'est un
ultra conservateur. Il avait été
l'économiste en chef de George Bush et
il nous avait dit dans une réunion de
chargé TD, on a parmi nos étudiants le
prochain président des États-Unis et je
veux formater la façon dont il pense.
Donc qu'est-ce qu'il fait Grégory Mancu
? Vous pouvez acheter son manuel qui aux
États-Unis coûte littéralement 150
dollars. 150 dollars le manuel aux
États-Unis doit coûter 40 € en France.
Vous achetez son manuel, le manuel de
base, il y a aucune équation. Il y a
aucune équation parce que le mec, il est
malin. Donc il vous raconte de façon
littéraire, il vous embobine et il vous
explique que l'État est toujours le
problème et que le marché est toujours
la solution. Et il vous fait le marché
du travail, la mondialisation sur tous
les problèmes.
Le marché est toujours la solution quand
il est pas administré d'une façon
soviétique par les banques centrales.
Oui. Non mais justement alors tout ce
qui ne va pas simplement il n'en parle
pas. Il n'en parle pas. Et quand
j'enseignais là-bas, toutes les
semaines, je fais la même chose au
tableau, la courbe d'offre et la courbe
de demande. Quel que soit le sujet,
l'offre et la demande, l'optimum et puis
l'intervention étatique qui vient tout
faire merder avec des subventions ou de
la taxation ou des restrictions
quantitatives des quotas par exemple
dans l'agriculture comme on avait connu
par exemple les surplus agricoles qui
avaient donné lieu à la création des
restos du cœur en France à l'époque où
la la politique agricole commune
subventionnait à mort les agriculteurs
européens. Bref, donc toutes les
semaines, on faisait la même chose et
évidemment les étudiants étaient
totalement convaincus. Et je peux vous
garantir que le mec un tel génie de la
pédagogie à l'américaine, c'est
Hollywood. Que queles que soient vos
opinions politiques, quand vous avez 18
ans, c'est quelqu'un des étudiants qui
rentrent à Harvard, mais vous n'importe
qui à 18 ans, vous lisez son bouquin, je
vous garantis qu'il vous convainc. Il
met des petits articles de presse, il y
a des blagounettes, il y a des cartoons,
il y a des vraies statistiques, plein de
vraies statistiques tirées de la réalité
qui vont dans son sens, qui sont bien
présentés. Le mec, c'est un génie de la
pédagogie. Et après par contre
effectivement, il y a des maths, mais il
y a des maths pertinents pour ceux qui
se destinent à faire de la recherche en
économie.
J'ai une question de Hassan.
Ouais. Euh
qui est une question en hommage et en
référence à Bernard Stigler.
Ouais. Euh selon lui, qu'est-ce qui fait
que la vie vaut la peine d'être vécue ?
Alors, avant que vous enchaînez sur pour
répondre à Hassan, moi je vais vous
poser une question avant et je suis
désolé Hassan.
Comment ça va vous dans votre vie ?
Attendez, attendez,
je crois que vous aviez
Comment comment ça va dans votre vie ?
On on nous a attiré l'attention sur
vous, on vous connaissait pas du tout.
Notre communauté est venue nous chercher
à la à la suite d'un tweet où vous aviez
pris conscience de la réalité des
choses.
Quand vous êtes économiste, vous avez
l'air connecté quand même avec les vrais
gens. Qu'est-ce que ça vous fait
intérieurement ?
Bah euh déjà ça si vous voulez ça fait
après quand j'ai vu le cirque de la
recherche économique pendant ma thèse où
je participais à des colloques, je
présentais mon travail et tout ça, j'ai
tout de suite su que ça me plaisait pas
parce que dans dans les conférences
d'économistes, c'est un processus
incroyablement industriel. C'est-à-dire
que chacun a exactement 10 minutes pour
présenter son papier que personne n'a
lu. Il y a éventuellement une ou deux
questions bidon et on enchaîne et on
enchaîne et on est l'œil sur la monte.
Bim bim bim et en fait on y va pour la
bouffe gratuite parce qu'on est pauvre
et aussi parce que le labo va nous payer
un billet d'avion et de nuit d'hôtel aux
États-Unis ou dans un pays sympa et tout
ça. Bon voilà. Donc moi, j'ai très vite
arrêté la recherche. À l'époque, j'étais
un laboratoire extrêmement riche parce
qu'on avait décroché un contrat européen
et donc je savais déjà que j'avais des
conditions de travail que j'aurais plus
jamais après à la fac. J'étais dans un
laboratoire de l'école normale
supérieure financé par le CNRS.
J'achetais tous les bouquins américains
que je voulais. Je pouvais tous les
coloques du monde pendant l'année,
c'était la fête parce qu'on a on était
pété de tune euh parce que de toute
façon un métier où en fait on a besoin
de très peu d'argent pour travailler. On
n'est pas dans des laboratoires avec des
machines qui vent des millions d'euros
comme un saclet ou je sais pas où. Bref,
et donc moi en fait euh
enfin ça va répondre en partie à votre
question. Il est bien évident que pour
l'immense majorité des économistes de
France, soit me connaissent pas
évidemment, soit ceux qui me connaissent
évidemment ne me considèrent pas du tout
comme un économiste. Et y compris mes
amis collègues euh hétérodoxes,
économistes de gauche font semblant,
mais tout le monde sait qu'ils font
semblant, de me considérer comme un
économiste. Non, mais ça c'est vraiment
c'est ça strictement de parce que euh
mais mais c'est légitime, c'est la
logique sociale et c'était exactement
aussi le cas de Bernard Maris et j'ai
fait cette erreur moi-même avec Bernard
Maris. Donc je comprends tout à fait ce
qui se passe, c'est que je ne joue pas
leur jeux, je ne vais pas leur cologue,
je lis pas leur papiers abscon et de
même qu'il ne lisent pas mes bouquins
parce qu'ils pensent qu'ils vont rien
apprendre parce que c'est de la
vulgarisation
qui est un terme vraiment je trouve
atroce. Et donc j'ai mis moi extrêmement
longtemps à me considérer comme un
économiste et je remercie beaucoup
Christian Chavagneux qui m'a commandé le
dernier bouquin que j'ai écrit où j'ai
fourni
qui s'appelle économie. On n pas tout
essayé et c'est un bouquin où en fait
c'est pas moi qui parle. Euh
c'est-à-dire qu'il y a 10 chapitres
thématiques qui peuvent être lus de
façon totalement indépendante. Un
chapitre sur la mondialisation, un
chapitre sur le chômage, un chapitre sur
les inégalités, un chapitre sur la
politique industrielle, un chapitre sur
l'Europe, un chapitre sur la transition
écologique. Et en fait ce que j'ai lu
littéralement des centaines de bouquins
d'études et cetera, j'ai vraiment bossé
comme un taré. Et avec un gros gros
travail d'écriture, je permets au
lecteur en fait de lire les meilleurs
travaux d'économistes du monde et donc
de gagner un temps considérable et de
voir qu'en fait parmi les gens sérieux,
parce qu'il y en a parmi les gens
sérieux, il y a un consensus pour dire
que la révolution conservatrice des
années 80 a été une énorme erreur.
Et en fait chez les économistes sérieux
ça commence à se dire mais on a du ils
ont du mal à le dire dans le public
parce que ça ruine évidemment toute la
le prestig en ils pensent que ça va
ruiner tout le prestige de la
profession. Un des bouquins les plus
incroyables que j'ai lu ces dernières
années, c'est le bouquin de Gabriel
Zucman et d'Emmanuel Sez qui sont deux
économistes français brillantissime,
prof à Berkley, il est disponible en
français et il vous raconte pourquoi et
comment on a baissé à tort les impôts
sur les haut revenus, sur les
patrimoines, sur les entreprises dans
les années 80 avec l'accord des
démocrates américains. Ils expliquent
très finement ce qui s'est passé et
pourquoi ensuite, ce que je disais tout
à l'heure, on a laissé se créer des
entreprises monstrueuses qui sont
aujourd'hui beaucoup plus fortes que les
États. Typiquement voilà, Facebook,
Google ou encore même les
multinationales de l'énergie, les
laboratoires pharmaceutiques dont
littéralement nos vies dépendent
d'aujourd'hui. Il y a aucun débat en
France sur le fait de dire pourquoi les
labos sont privés. C'est hallucinant.
C'est que même là,
surtout qu'en général, c'est financé
avec notre pognon
et qu'en plus évidemment Exactement.
Mais en fait, vous avez raison, le
secteur privé est très largement un faux
secteur privé, surtout évidemment dans
le domaine de la santé puisque de toute
façon à la fin des fins, c'est la SQ qui
finance tout ça, soit directement, soit
indirectement. Exactement. Et donc dans
mes petits moments d'espoir pour
répondre à votre question,
pourquoi des petits moments d'espoir ?
Parce que ils sont brefs. Alors bon, il
y a quand même les il y a quand même les
matchs du 15 de France avec Antoine
Dupont, donc ça c'est quand même
important. Mais mais euh quand vous
lisez par exempleur
le le dernier livre de Joseph Stigitz
disponible aussi en français,
on a reçu aussi ici
qui est voilà qui est pour moi le plus
grand économiste vivant qui
des fois il raconte un peu des conneries
he
qui est un mec fabuleux. Donc ce livre
s'intitule pouvoir, peuple et profit. Et
quand vous le lisez, si vous avez un peu
de culture,
très bon bouquin,
non mais c'est plus qu'un très bon
bouquin, c'est que c'est un bouquin qui
est intégralement marxiste. Qui est
intégralement marxiste. Qu'est-ce que
vous dit Stiglit si vous dit "Les
entreprises aux États-Unis sont devenues
tellement énormes qu'elles grugent leurs
clients parce qu'elles surfacturent,
qu'elles corrompent les gouvernements
parce qu'elles achètent littéralement
les élus et elles écrasent la
concurrence." Donc dans ce livre, très
calmement à l'américaine de façon hyper
factuelle, Joseph Siglis vous dit "Aux
États-Unis, on n'est plus en démocratie
et on n'est plus dans une économie de
marché." Voilà, il vous le dit,
il vous dit il vous le dit tranquillou.
Le mec est pris Nobel et et j'ai
rarement vu un gars qui n'a qui n'avait
pas la grosse tête comme ça.
Il est arrivé super coup, il était
absolument. Je reviens à la question
d'Hassan.
H
question en hommage et en référence à
Bernard Stigler. Selon lui, qu'est-ce
qui fait que la vie vaut la peine d'être
vécue ?
Tu veux dire selon moi,
bon, je sais pas si c'est la réponse qui
intéresse beaucoup de gens, mais euh
bon, moi je suis quelqu'un de, vous
savez, il y a ce truc maintenant sur les
hypersensibles. Donc moi, je suis
quelqu'un effectivement d'hypersensible.
Donc je je passe par voilà, des milliers
d'émotions par jour. Donc il y a plein
de moments super agréables, plein de
moments super difficiles. Bon voilà,
c'est mais je veux dire même les moments
super difficiles peuvent être super
intéressants. Par exemple là, avant de
venir à votre émission, comme à chaque
fois avant une grosse interview, euh
émotionnellement je descends très très
bas. C'est-à-dire que je suis en
panique, je j'ai envie de vomir, j'ai
envie d' être sous terre, je suis
totalement terrorisé.
Alors est-ce que c'était nécessaire ?
Et là oui parce que je sais que je
fonctionne comme ça. C'est-à-dire que je
sais pas si là je suis bon ou si les
gens me trouvent intéressants.
Vous êtes bon. Mais je sais que pour
être bon, il faut que je passe par là.
Et donc je me laisse descendre parce
qu'il y a une sorte d'effondrement
émotionnel qui est extrêmement violent,
qui est extrêmement difficile à vivre,
mais auquel maintenant je commence à
être habitué. Et bon, il y a des
témoignages, voilà, d'artistes ou de
chanteurs qui racontent la même chose.
Moi, je suis comme ça et donc je sais,
je me laisse faire petits exercices de
sophrologie pour pas descendre trop bas
quand même, mais je sais que c'est
là-dedans. Euh par exemple, je l'ai vécu
aussi quand j'ai passé plein de voilà
d'euros hein pour mes examens, mes
concours. Déjà à cette époque-là, je me
rendais compte, je descendais très bas.
Au début, ça me faisait totalement
paniquer et je et et plusieurs fois,
c'est les fois où j'étais descendu le
plus bas que j'avais été le meilleur par
la suite.
Et c'est ça qui qui vous donne c'est ça
la chose à vivre. C'est qui ?
Ah bah c'est vrai que moi je trouve
ce qui vaut la peine.
Ah bah moi c'est vrai que je trouve ça
beaucoup plus
prochain tend de la main.
Ah bah si. Alors là le truc qui me
manque le plus ce qui est le plus
important dans ma vie mis à part ma
fille c'est les étudiants. C'estàd
qu'effectivement j'adore faire cours.
J'adore faire cours. J'adore apprendre
d'eux. Je suis dans un lieu où j'ai
quand même beaucoup de chance où déjà
j'ai peu d'étudiants parce que je suis
cœur master. J'ai des étudiants euh qui
viennent d'Europe, qui viennent d'autres
pays. Des étudiants chinois, des
étudiants américains. Chacun amène son
expérience. On a j'ai malheureusement
pas du tout assez d'heures de cours avec
eux, mais j'adore leur apprendre des
trucs, les faire réagir, les faire
marrer, les émouvoir, apprendre d'eux.
La relation avec les étudiants, moi
c'est ce qui me fait vibrer. Et comme
tous les enseignants là de comme tous
les vrais enseignants,
c'est ce qui me manque le plus avec le
Covid. J'adore ça. Maintenant, c'est
vrai qu' aussi je préfère être là que
être chez moi en train de faire la
vaisselle. Ça c'est sûr que ça c'est pas
ça ça passionne pas trop de faire les
petites tâches domestiques chez moi.
Mais ouais
des fois ça prête à méditation hein.
Mais alors des fois ça prête à
méditation déjà c'est vrai que
maintenant je fais la vaisselle sans
mettre la radio puisque ça m'énerve trop
et en faitw. Non mais je mets rien du
tout et en fait je pense à plein de
trucs et c'est assez apaisant le soir de
faire sa petite vaisselle puis quand on
a sa petite maison rangée, on est
content et tout ça donc on peut trouver
du plaisir partout, il y a aucun
problème.
Question question de Missile Exo 7,
il vote pour qui en 2022 ?
Alors moi je en 2022 là, j'ai très envie
de voter Poutou s'il se présente.
Ah ouais. Euh parce que justement il y a
je trouve il y a une sincérité
programme économique qui vous fait
marrer.
Euh bon je le connais pas pas plus que
ça mais j'aime la cohérence de la
personne. c'estd l'impression d'avoir
quelqu'un qui déjà dans son activité
c'est quelqu'un qui travaille, qui est
dans la réalité et et c'est vrai que je
je je me vois vraiment mal voter pour un
professionnel de la politique et
j'aimerais vraiment s'il y en a par
extraordinaire qui m'écoutent que il
faudrait vraiment qu'il comprennent tous
ces gens-là que en fait malgré tout ce
que j'ai dit sur l'éducation nationale
on est quand même un pays éduqué on est
comme un pays où il y a des gens qui
réfléchissent et il faudrait vraiment
juste qu'il nous arrêtent tous de nous
parler comme des débiles.
vraiment qu'il s'arrête parce qu'on a
tous compris que la situation était hors
de contrôle depuis des années et
simplement qui nous disent bah ouais
écoutez la dégradation écologique c'est
planétaire, j'y peux rien. La crise
économique c'est le Covid, j'y peux
rien. Maintenant je vais essayer. Je
pense
qu'il y en a un qui a bien compris ce
qui se passait et c'est pas par hasard,
c'est le général de Villier parce que
justement je pense que l'armée est un
des rares lieux aujourd'hui où il y a
encore un tout petit peu de mixité
sociale. J'ai pas lu son dernier
bouquin, je le lirai pas mais il
s'appelle réparer la France et ça je
pense qu'il a bien
lirait pas
parce que je j'ai d'autres choses à
faire mais je veux dire je suis sûr que
c'est intéressant mais parce que j'ai
déjà un énorme retard de lecture sur
d'autres trucs que je trouve plus
important pour moi
comme quoi
euh comme quoi bah ça par exemple voyez
ça j'arrive pas vous
excusez-moi je vous ai coupé
je suis en train de lire la richesse des
nations d'Adame Smith ça fait des années
que j'essaie de le lire là maintenant
j'essaie de le poser pour j'aimerais
enfin finir ce ce bouquin prodigieux
bref et donc je pense qu'aujourd'hui on
aurait besoin besoin de quelqu'un qui
disent "Écoutez, je vais juste essayer
d'arrêter la dégradation. Je vais
essayer de faire en sorte qu'en Sundy,
il y ait plus des quartiers qui soient
tenu par des dealers de drogue. Je vais
faire en sorte que dans les collèges, il
y a des profs qui soient bons et qu'il y
ait plus de profs de français qui
fassent des fautes de français parce
qu'il y a plein de témoignages sur
internet qui sont très impressionnants
d'instit qui aujourd'hui font des fautes
de français tellement leur niveau est
faible. Je sais que c'est violent ce que
je dis là mais c'est la réalité. notre
pays. Oui, mais c'est il y a plein de
témoignages. Moi, j'ai des témoignages.
Le niveau scolaire baissé comme ça quand
on dit que les élèves de CE2, ils ont
perdu 3 ans.
Vous avez vu les classements
internationaux en sciences, on s'est
complètement effondré. Moi, j'ai
plusieurs témoignages récents, c'est
sidérant de potes privilégiés qui
habitent dans des beaux quartiers à
Paris dont les qui ont des gamins au
collège, dont les profs de français ou
de math sont absents pendant des mois
des mois. J'ai un exemple, un prof de
français absent pendant 1 an dans un
collège public parisien non remplacé non
remplacé pendant 1 an dans un collège
public parisien dans un beau quartier.
On en est là aujourd'hui. On en est là.
On est not notre pays. C'est pour ça que
je vous parlais des États-Unis. On n'y
croit pas. Moi longtemps avec la culture
de go, j'ai dit oui, les ghetto, la
discrimination et cetera, c'est les
États-Unis. Je pense qu'il faudrait
vraiment qu'on se réveille et que et
c'est très facile, toutes les enquêtes
le montent mais simplement il faut juste
discuter avec les bons journalistes
parce qu'il y en a, avec les bons
sociologues parce qu'il y en a, avec les
bons économistes, il y en a quand même
quelques-uns. Des gens qui connaissent
la réalité. Bah sur la question de la
jeunesse, par exemple, Camille Penny qui
est un de mes potes qui est sociologue
fait des travaux remarquables et il
montre depuis des années dans ses
bouquins de façon très claire, très
accessible, le poids énorme du
déterminisme social et l'ampleur
hallucinante des inégalités sociales en
France. selon votre la famille dans
laquelle vous êtes né. Et donc
effectivement notre pays est en train de
se s'effondrer et il y a un lien
évidemment avec la montée très forte
hein de la question de l'identité dont
on voit qui est en train de bouffer tous
les débats parce qu'on a perdu
effectivement de plus en plus de gens en
tout cas ont perdu la conscience de
vivre dans un même pays, l'espoir qu'il
y ait des solutions collectives. On voit
que tout ça est est en train de
s'effondrer. Si je continue avec mon
petit tableau hyper sombre, on a un très
gros problème par exemple de
représentation médiatique des syndicats.
C'est-à-dire que moi je ne suis pas
syndiqué. Je connais à peu près personne
qui est syndiqué et en fait personne
n'est syndiqué en France. Personne.
Il faut dire qu' aussi les syndicats,
ils ont un peu abusé quand même. Non
non mais alors
la vie de château
machin
que j'aime bien les frais
et que vas-y je me mets fait manipuler
par le gouvernement hein. Les syndicats.
Bon hein.
Non mais alors moi je bon
d'accord. On n pas d'accord. Il y en
alors il y en a effectivement qui se
sont laissés aller mais ce que je veux
dire
laisser aller
c'est beau.
Non non mais ce que je veux dire c'est
que quand vous quand vous
789 on aurait réglé ça différemment hein
quand vous écoutez les infos.
Alors j'ai j'ai un j'ai un très bon pote
qui s'appelle Mathieu Co qui est
économiste à la CGT donc il me le
pardonnera mais il je lui ai déjà dit
donc il le sait. Quand vous écoutez les
infos, vous avez l'impression qu'il y a
un truc qui existe qui s'appelle la CGT.
La quoi
la CGT ? Ouais. Les ballons, les
ballons,
la Confédération générale du travail,
vous avez même l'impression que c'est
des gens qui ont de l'importance dans le
pays et cetera. Oui, mais dans le
secteur privé, dans le secteur privé
aujourd'hui en France, le taux de
syndicalisation, je crois qu'il doit
être à 2 %. C'est-à-dire que 98 % des
gens qui travaillent ne sont pas
syndiqués. Et quand vous regardez les
médias, la CFDT, la CGT, les énormes
interviews dans le monde et cetera, vous
voyez, ça c'est très très grave de faire
ça. C'est-à-dire qu'on continue
d'alimenter à la fois à droite l'idée
qu'il y aurait un spectre des syndicats
alors que les syndicats n'existent plus.
Ils ont plus aucun impact dans le
fonctionnement de la société. C'est
évident. Ils
l'encadr
et à gauche, non mais et à gauche, on
continue de faire croire qu' Mais vous
voyez, ça n'existe plus. C'est-à-dire
que moi, c'est des discussions que j'ai
tout le temps avec mes parents. C'est
c'est c'est parce qu'effectivement les
gens ne se rendent pas compte de leur
âge et c'est normal à quel point le
monde dans lequel ils ont grandi, le
lequel ils ont vécu leur vie d'adulte,
ce monde n'existe plus. Je discutais la
semaine dernière avec un un joueur de
rugby qui était un retraité de la SNCF
et qui doit avoir 60 ans. Et cet
homme-là, comme beaucoup de gens,
il a vu voilà, il a vu disparaître son
monde. C'estàd je vois par exemple, on
continue de parler de service public en
France. Vous voyez ça ? C'est très
intéressant. Moi je considère qu'il n'y
a bon peut-être à la rigueur peut-être
l'armée ou bon peut-être la police, j'en
sais rien, mais il y a quasiment plus de
services public en France.
Oui. Ouais, c'est ça. Les pompiers.
Euh
la police, il y a
Est-ce que la police c'est un service
public ?
Oui, je dirais oui, c'est quand même
ouis.
C'est pas c'est pas
Mais il y a un économiste sociologue qui
s'appelle Albert Hchman. C'est quelqu'un
que j'aime beaucoup. Et en fait, il
expliquait il y a déjà très longtemps
dans les années 50 et 60, il expliquait
un truc très important. il disait euh
bon je vous raconte juste l'histoire.
Donc il est
là j'ai une bonne question internet qui
doit venir là.
OK. Moi je je la fait courte d'ailleurs.
C'est super intéressant. Donc il est
jeune économiste. D'accord. Il est
américain mais il est en Inde à ce
moment-là. D'accord. Et euh donc il y a
euh il y a un chemin de fer qui a le
monopole du transport entre deux villes
parce qu'il y a pas de route. D'accord.
L'État indien local construit une route.
Lui c'est un économiste, il se dit vu
qu'il y a la route concurrence avec le
train, la qualité du train qui était
extrêmement mauvaise va s'améliorer pour
garder les gens pour éviter qu'ils
prennent la bagnole. Il se passe
exactement l'inverse. C'est-à-dire que
les riches prennent la voiture, il y a
plus que les pauvres dans le train et
donc les ressources de la compagnie
publique baissent et surtout aussi les
salariés de la compagnie publique ne
sont plus motivés. Parce que là, je vais
dire un truc d'une extrême violence,
mais c'est l'arrêté sociologique. Les
gens n'aiment pas travailler pour les
pauvres hein. Regardez quand vous allez
dans les boutiques de luxe, les
vendeuses qui gagnent trois fois moins
que vous comme elles vous prennent de
haut parce qu'elles sont vendeuses chez
quartier ou chez Fauchon. Ça c'est très
intéressant. Les gens comme les vendeurs
de voiture chez Audi. Non.
Ouais, ça je connais pas. Mais enfin
Fauchon non plus, mais plus
enfin bref, mais voyez l'idée. Les gens
aiment bien travailler pour les riches
et les gens n'aiment pas travailler pour
les pauvres. Et c'est un problème
d'ailleurs dans l'éducation nationale.
Là aussi, c'est très euh l'économie
c'est rude mais la la sociologie c'est
carrément violent. c'est qu'il y a plein
d'études sociologiques qui montrent hein
que euh les enseignants comme les
policiers, comme les magistrats sont
toujours biaisés en faveur des
catégories sociales et sont beaucoup
plus cléments, hein. C'estd que le petit
blanc à lunette, fils de de médecin qui
a pas rendu son devoir, c'est beaucoup
moins grave que si vous avez une autre
couleur de peau et que votre père était
boueur. Ça c'est très très net, hein. Et
c'est c'est même un classique de la
littérature sociologique s'appelle
l'effet pigmalon. Et ça, quand vous
dites ça à un prof, c'est d'une violence
absolue et je sais que je le fais aussi.
parce que c'est des trucs sont tellement
profonds qu'on ne s'en rend pas compte.
Bref, la leçon d'Hirchman, c'est que un
vrai service public, c'est quoi ? C'est
un service public qui est en monopole.
Qui est en monopole parce que comme ça,
il y a toute la société qui est obligée
pour prendre les termes de l'économiste,
de le consommer. Et c'est en ce sens-là
qu'il y a quasiment plus de services
publics en France. C'est-à-dire que si
vous voulez avoir un bon service public,
il faut que tout le système éducatif
soit public. Il faut que tout le système
de santé soit public. Pourquoi ? Parce
que quand tout le système est public et
ben le fils de riche, la fille du PDG de
la société générale, elle est obligée
d'aller dans le même hôpital que vous.
Ces enfants, ils sont obligés d'aller
dans la même école que celui de
l'boueurs. Et qu'est-ce qu'ils font ces
gens-là ? Ils râent. C'est des gros
râleurs. Et donc, les services publics
sont obligés d'être de bonne qualité
parce qu'ils ont face à eux des clients
entre guillemets qui gueulent. Ce qui
s'est passé en Angleterre, ce qui s'est
passé aux États-Unis avec tous les
processus de privatisation, c'est que
les services publics sont devenus des
services pour les pauvres et donc
évidemment leurs ressources financières
ont baissé et ils ont pas attiré
évidemment les meilleurs profs, les
meilleurs médecins. Quand vous êtes aux
États-Unis, c'est une évidence que si
vous êtes brillant, si vous faites des
études de médecine, si vous devenez prof
à la fac, à quelques exceptions près
parce qu'il reste quelques faces
publiques brillantes aux États-Unis
comme Berkley, mais quand vous êtes
brillant, évidemment vous allez bosser
dans le privé. C'est juste évident dans
la société et dans ces sociétés là
bosser dans le public c'est un échec.
C'est un échec. Moi, je me rappelle, ça
avait marqué, vous savez, dans le film
JFK où on voit euh la reconstitution de
la scène euh au tribunal et à un moment,
il y a Kevin Kosner qui dit euh "On a
été aidé dans notquête, on a reçu de
l'argent et il dit des gens pauvres, des
enseignants
et ça m'avait frappé bah pour moi
enseignant c'était un bon boulot à
l'époque, j'étais jeune quand j'ai vu le
film mais non dans le contexte américain
en fait quand vous êtes enseignant dans
public bah vous êtes pauvre, c'est juste
normal et bah c'est ce qui arrive en
France aujourd'hui. Et aujourd'hui dans
des facs de banlieu comme la mienne,
tout le monde est pauvre. Enfin, en tout
cas de plus en plus de gens sont plus en
plus pauvres. C'est que les étudiants
sont pauvres. Même hors Covid, ils n'ont
pas les moyens d'acheter des bouquins.
C'est une certitude. Ils travaillent 15
20 heures par semaine pour se payer
leurs études. Évidemment, ils échouent
parce que c'est trop dur. La fac est
pauvre. La fac est pauvre. Regarde,
regardez.
Ils peuvent même plus bosser pour payer
leurs études. Donc ça va être d'autant
plus délè
c'est ça. Euh moi, par exemple, des
voyez des publications basiques pour un
économiste comme le Financial Times ou
The économist. Moi ma fac n'y est pas
abonnée parce que c'est trop cher.
J'arrête pas de cartonner. Bon, je sais
que c'est très bête de ma part les profs
du secondaire, mais
Forbs, ils sont abonnés à Forbs. Non,
non, non, à rien. Par exemple, ce qui
est hallucinant, surtout maintenant avec
le numérique, c'est que les profs de
collège et de lycée n'ont pas accès aux
bases de données où il y a la presse
française, où il y a la presse
internationale et où il y a les revues
scientifiques. C'est-à-dire que
l'éducation nationale, non seulement
enfin en fait toutes ces institutions
sont extrêmement violentes avec nous.
Moi quand j'arrive à ma fac, je me dis
je suis une merde parce que ma fac elle
est juste immonde. Et parce que je sais
que ça m'est encore arrivé dans mes
derniers cours au mois d'octobre, je
suis arrivé le matin dans ma salle de
cours, il y avait pas de courant et
c'est une
3 jours. C'est ça.
Voilà, c'est ça. Et j'ai appris voilà
qu'il y avait pas de courant depuis 3
jours. Bon bah qu'est-ce que j'ai fait ?
J'étais furieux et j'ai dit aux
étudiants et ben je me casse les amis.
Je me pour je me lève et je me casse. Je
m'étais pas assis donc je suis reparti
immédiatement. Et et c'est vrai que
j'aimerais que nous et là je m'adresse à
nos amis de gauche et cetera, je pense
que c'est très important qu'on arrête
qu'on arrête de défendre l'État.
Pourquoi est-ce qu'on défend cet
employeur qui nous maltraite ?
Aujourd'hui, c'est très connu la
précarité dans les facs, dans les
hôpitaux et est plus élevé que dans le
privé. Le pire employeur de France,
c'est l'État. Pourquoi est-ce que nous,
tous les gens de gauche, on maintient
cette fiction alors que tout le monde
sait, les flics sont humiliés, les
commissariats sentent la piste, leurs
bagnoles, elles ont 40 ans. On se
rappelle de SarkoZi, les mecs qui
passaient leur téléphone, leur coup de
fil sur leur téléphone portable perso.
Euh, à l'hôpital, c'est pas la peine
d'en parler, on leur crache.
Écoutez avec cette de moyennes. Donc
bon.
Oui, mais c'est la conséquence de ça.
Voyez, ça c'est la cause. Ce que vous
dites, c'est la conséquence. À
l'hôpital, on leur crache dessus. On
arrive au bout d'un an d'épidémie à ne
pas recruter des fonction des
infirmières et on a et on sait qu'il y a
beaucoup de gens qui vont quitter leur
boulot qui l'ont déjà fait. Il y a plein
d'articles là-dessus parce que c'est
juste trop dur. On leur crache à la
gueule au au milieu de la pire pandémie
qui comme vous le dites
ouais qui comme comme
et on leur donne des médailles.
Ouais, c'est ça.
Des petites sucettes. C'est des quand on
quand on prend les métiers les uns après
les autres, tout le monde est d'accord
et là aussi dans la population pour dire
quand je suis justement sur BFM, j'ai
plein de patrons du MF qui disent "Ah
oui, c'est sûr, les profs sont pas assez
payés mais c'est les mecs qui arrêtent
pas de raller en même temps sur les
dépenses publiques et voi pas le lien un
petit peu évident entre les deux." Et
donc je me dis comment ça se fait que
nous à gauche il y a ce mythe de l'État
alors que l'État littéralement nous
marche sur la gueule tous les jours et
et évidemment le pire c'est pas nous
c'est que moi ce qui me fait souffrir
quand j'arrive à ma fac c'est que je me
dis mes étudiants, je vais leur faire
cours dans une salle qui est moche qui a
pas été repeinte depuis 20 ans. Il va
manquer des tables. Il y a pas de prise
pour qu'ils rechargent leur téléphone
portable pendant la journée. Ils vont à
la BU. Il y a pas les bouquins récents
des bouquins de 20 balles. Moi quand je
sors un livre, je dois acheter moi-même
si je veux qu'il y ait 10 exemplaires à
la BU, c'est moi qui les achète parce
que la BU, elle achète un exemplaire du
livre et je dois chouer pour qu' en
achète deux. C'est pas mes droits
d'auteur. Donc ça aussi c'est important
à savoir. Les droits d'auteur euh en
France en moyenne c'est 8 %. D'accord ?
C'est 8 %. Donc quand vous vendez un
bouquin 20 € il y a 1,50 € qui arrive
pour l'auteur dans le meilleur des cas
parce que c'est pas toujours le cas. Et
ça c'est brut avant un pot tout ce que
vous voulez et cetera. Et évidemment
pour écrire un livre souvent vous avez
des dépenses importantes à faire en
documentation et cetera. Bref, donc
voilà. Et donc je me dis qu'est-ce qui
se passe ? Quand est-ce qu'on va se
réveiller ? Et je pense que j'aimerais
j'aimerais justement que la gauche
dénonce l'État pour pour maltraitance
pour tout ce qu'on veut.
Mais l'État c'est nous.
Bah non, moi l'État moi c'est pas moi je
suis employé de l'État. Mais
l'État c'est nous.
Non non non non non. L'État c'est pas
nous. L'État
alors l'État c'est quoi ? C'est la haute
fonction publique qui se planque qui a
les bonnes places et
ah bah oui non mais là pour le coup
l'état ça ça s'observe c'est que si je
prends mon métier l'État c'est que c'est
le ministère de l'enseignement supérieur
et la recherche qui ne recrute pas par
exemple qu'est-ce qui se passe dans les
fac aujourd'hui ça c'est très
intéressant mais depuis des années hein
donc là on a une pénurie de poste
d'enseignants qui est colossal mais vous
avez quand même des gens qui font des
thèses donc vous avez littéralement moi
je l'ai vécu c'est d'une violence
incroyable vous avez un poste mettons de
m de conf en économie. D'accord ?
Donc le plus petit,
voilà le de toute façon, il y a que deux
grades. Si on simplifie, donc c'est très
simple. C'est un peu comme le caps et la
greg dans le secondaire. Donc vous avez
un poste et vous avez un poste où les
deux ou 3 ans, mettons dans une petite
fac, vous avez des centaines de
candidats. Des centaines de candidats,
vous faites une présélection et vous
auditionnez, on va dire, allez 10, 15,
20 candidats. Qu'est-ce qui se passe ?
Depuis des années déjà, et ça personne
le dit, il faut le dire. Les candidats
sont meilleurs que les gens du jury
parce qu'il y a tellement peu de postes
que les candidats sont meilleurs que les
gens du jury dont je fait partie. Mais
attention, pas âge équivalent dans
l'absolu. C'est-à-dire que vous avez des
jeunes chercheurs de 30 ans qui ont des
publications que moi je n'ai pas et si
on fait les publications moyennes du
jury, des gens de 40 45 ans, 50 ans,
aujourd'hui le niveau moyen des
publications du jury est inférieur à
celle des candidats et on est gêné par
rapport à ça et on se le dit tous entre
nous et on le dit pas à l'extérieur
évidemment parce que c'est la honte.
Bref, on recrute cette personne-là.
Cette personne-là, elle a en général
fait des posts doc, elle a enseigné aux
États-Unis, elle a mené des projets de
recherche déjà au niveau international.
Cette personnel, c'est déjà un chercheur
confirmé. Et qu'est-ce qui va se passer
après ? Cette personnel, elle va se
retrouver à faire cours en première
année à des gamins de 18 ans qui ont le
niveau qu'ils ont. et ben on crée du
malheur. C'est-à-dire qu'on recrute déjà
pas du tout un prof, on recrute que sur
la recherche. Et ensuite dans ses
relations humaines, cette personne-là,
elle va être avant tout un enseignant ou
une enseignante. Et elle va vouloir
évidemment parler de sa recherche, de
son travail à des jeunes lycéens qui
sortent du bac et qui malheureusement
pour beaucoup d'entre eux ont des
grosses difficultés de concentration, de
mémorisation, de capacité d'analyse qui
sont juste pas bons, pas bons, pas bons.
Et donc
parce que quoi ? Ils sont dans un milieu
socioculturel néfaste parce que quoi ?
parce qu'ils sont parce qu'ils ont pas
de tune parce qu'ils mangent pas parce
qu'ils sont mais parce que là il faut le
dire non parce que effectivement moi je
me rappelle je me rappelle très bien de
ça
parce qu'ils sont tellement dans une
précarité que ils peuvent
Non non mais non mais parce que alors
justement j' discuté avec un prof en
lycée qui m'a donné l'explication il lui
pour lui l'explication c'est en 1985 il
y a le congrès de la fédération de
l'éducation nationale la Fen qui est une
organisation qui n'existe plus
aujourd'hui. Et à ce moment-là, il y a
une idée qui n'est pas mauvaise, qui est
de dire le système éducatif français est
beaucoup trop hiérarchique et c'est un
système, comme on dirait en terme
d'économiste d'offre, c'est-à-dire que
on s'intéresse pas au clients, c'est je
fais mon truc et c'est aux élèves de
s'adapter et on voyait bien que ça
déconnait de plus en plus. Donc on s'est
dit, on va replacer l'élève au centre du
système éducatif. Mais en fait,
qu'est-ce qu'on a fait ? On a tout lâché
et on a pris le pire du clientélisme. Et
je me rappelle très bien en 91, j'avais
un prof d'histoire que j'adorais,
monsieur Rissant à Lyon qui il nous
faisait des imitations de Churchill, de
Staline en cours, c'était grandiose. Il
nous fait revivre Yalta, le mec c'est un
génie et je me rappelle, je discutais
beaucoup avec lui déjà, il me disait
"Vous rendez compte Gill, on nous
demande dans la notation du bac de ne
plus prendre en compte dans les
dissertations d'histoire géographie les
fautes de français.
en 91 il y a 30 ans. Et ce que me
raconte mon pote là qui est prof en
lycée, il me dit dans un bon lycée
parisien encore une fois, il me dit la
la porte du proviseur est littéralement
ouverte pour les élèves. Les élèves
savent qu'ils peuvent aller voir le
proviseur quand ils veulent. Lui lui
s'il veut voir le proviseur, il doit
prendre rendez-vous et il est loin de
toujours obtenir satisfaction. Une fois,
il était dans le hall du lycée, il est
pris à parti par un élève. Il se trouve
que l'élève a tort. Mais il me le dit
mon pote, c'est pas ça la question. Il
sait que le proviseur est là, le
proviseur entend. À aucun moment, il
vient défendre mon pote qui se retrouve
seul face à l'élève. Vous avez la
pression des familles, vous avez
effectivement maintenant les
dénonciations sur les réseaux sociaux.
C'est le fameux hashtag pas de vague.
Autant je suis critique vis-à-vis des
profs du secondaire qui je pense se sont
trop laissés infantilisés par
l'administration. Autant la vérité,
c'est que pour reprendre le vocabulaire
du président, eux, ils sont vraiment en
première ligne. Dans plein d'endroits,
leur sécurité physique est menacé, leur
santé mentale en tout cas est mise en
danger parce qu'ils sont contestés par
les élèves et parce que les élèves, ils
savent que derrière il y a personne.
Moi, je me rappelle, je suis dans un
environnement très privilégié parce que
pour reprendre votre question de la
sélection, j'enseigne en master et on
sélectionne à l'entrée. Donc c'est pour
ça que je vous dis, j'ai pas de
sélection à faire parce que la
sélection, elle a été faite à l'entrée
du master. Mais moi je leur dis aux
élèves, vous êtes 30, je suis tout seul,
j'ai aucune chance.
Même Antoine Dupont s'il est face à 30
adversaire, il peut pas passer. Donc la
réalité du rapport de force dans une
salle de classe, c'est que si les gamins
soit par leur éducation familiale, soit
par leur tempérament personnel, soit par
la menace de la sanction, s'il y a pas
quelque chose qui les calme, a s'ils
acceptent pas l'autorité comme dans le
temps jadis quand on se levait, quand le
prof rentrait en cours, qu' y avait tout
un truc et cetera, c'est évidemment pas
ce qu'il faudrait faire aujourd'hui.
Ça se fait plus ça.
Ça ça se fait plus. Mais
pourquoi vous demandez pas à vos élèves
de se lever quand vous arrivez ?
Ouais, pourquoi pas ? Ça pourrait être
marrant. Mais plus de
main sur la tête aussi. Non,
dans dans les trucs que disent Macron
que dit Macron mais qu'il fait pas, il a
il y a un truc qui pour moi en plus est
profondément de gauche qui dit pour
lequel il a raison, c'est quand il parle
de verticalité. On a besoin d'autorité
parce que l'autorité ça vous calme.
Qu'est-ce qu'il y a de pire pour un
enfant ? Qu'est-ce qu'il y a de pire
quand un enfant quand il a 2 ans ? On m
tout se joue. C'est d'avoir des parents
qui laissent faire ce qu'il veut. Et
d'ailleurs Jean Covici là dans la
préface de ce bouquin, il dit l'écologie
on nen veut pas parce que ça nous pose
des limites. Qu'est-ce qui fait que
beaucoup d'enfants sont malheureux et
après malheureux toute leur vie ? C'est
que quand vous quand vous produisez un
enfant qui a un processus très bizarre
au débutiste non ?
Ouais. Vous produisez un enfant quand il
nî, il faut qu'il soit au centre du
monde. Il faut que ça donne une scurité
affective totale. Il faut qu'il sache
que dès qu'il pleure, vous êtes là.
comme ça il est peinard, comme ça il est
serein, il est entendu, il a compris que
vous étiez là pour vous. Ce qui est très
difficile parce que ce qui se passe dans
votre couple à ce moment là, ce qui se
passe dans votre vie personnelle,
professionnelle, c'est très compliqué de
donner ça à un enfant. Mais quand vous y
arrivez, c'est génial. Mais ensuite très
vite, il est le roi du monde. OK, tu es
le roi du monde, tu t'aimes, c'est
génial, j'ai réussi la première partie.
Mais vers 2 ans, il y a ce moment où il
faut le mettre face au monde extérieur.
Alors, c'est moment où il touchent tous
les gamins et cetera. Et là, faut leur
dire non, faut les mettre au piquet,
faut leur dire il y a des limites.
Et ben cet apprentissage des limites, il
fait du bien aux enfants, il est calme.
Et ces limites, ça vous construit et
après vous peut-être passé votre vie à
essayer de de repousser ces limites.
Mais c'est fondamental de la
construction de la psychologie de
l'enfant. Et aujourd'hui, on a
malheureusement pour eux,
malheureusement pour eux, des des
enfants à l'école primaire, des enfants
au collège qui n'ont pas de limite, ni à
la maison, ni à l'école. Et c'est
horrible pour eux parce qu'ils savent
qu'ils ont besoin d'apprendre. Ils
savent qu'ils sont cons parce qu'on est
tous cons quand on est au collège. Quand
on est au collège, on est très très con.
Mais on sait qu'on est con. Évidemment
qu'on le sait. C'est comme ce que vous
disiez sur l'environnement. Je pense
qu'il y a beaucoup de gens qui font
semblant de s'en [__] mais qui s'en
foutent pas vraiment. Et donc le rôle de
la société, le rôle des adultes se dire
"OK, tu es con, OK, tu as envie de
raller, d'en faire le débile en cours,
ça me pose aucun problème. Mais moi, je
suis là pour autre chose et je suis là
pour toi. Je suis là pour ton toi dans 5
ans, dans 10 ans, dans 15 ans. Et donc
moi mes étudiants, je suis très sympa
comme ça, mais vous pouvez leur
demander, il y en a peut-être qui nous
regardent et cetera, je leur donne un
quantité de travail phénoménale et je
leur explose la tronche. Quand je me
fais chier à leur donner un chapitre de
bouquin que j'ai téléchargé, photocopié
par mes petits soins, que je leur fait
une présentation du texte, que je leur
pose des questions et je leur dis quand
vous revenez la semaine prochaine, le
poli de 20 pages, il doit être
martyrisé. Je leur dis quand vous lisez
un texte, c'est avec un crayon et je
leur apprends à lire. Et ce qu'il y a de
dingue, c'est qu'ils savent pas lire
alors qu'ils sont en master. Apprendre à
lire, c'est très compliqué. Qu'est-ce
que c'est lire ? Lire, c'est se poser
avec un texte. C'est mettre son
ordinateur portable éteint dans une
autre pièce. C'est se dire "Je discute
avec quelqu'un. J'ai la chance
incroyable d'avoir les meilleurs esprits
de la planète présents ou passé qui me
parlent. Ils sont là avec moi. Je me
pose et je me dis à chaque phrase "Mais
qu'est-ce qu'il dit le mec ? Est-ce que
je comprends ce qu'il dit ? Pourquoi il
dit ça ? Contre qui il s'oppose ?
Qu'est-ce qu'il essaie de me vendre ?
Est-ce que son argument tient la route ?
Moi, je leur dis aux étudiants, à la fin
d'avoir lu mes textes, mais vous devez
être cramé. Ça doit être dur
physiquement parce que moi, c'est comme
ça que je travaille. Et encore plus pour
le mémoire. Je dis, écrire un mémoire
mais c'est horrible. Écrire c'est une
torture mais je vous fais grandir. Je
suis là pour vous. Je suis là pour ça et
ce qui est marrant c'est qu'on voit il y
a des émissions comme Top Chef où c'est
exactement ça et qui ont vachement de
succès à cause de ça et il faut que
vraiment il faut que
cette révolte des profs dans l'éducation
nationale pédagogie par le coup de bâton
ou le par la martyrisé euh c'est c'est
difficile
non mais juste l'autorité l'autorité
ouais mais sans être tyrannique
non moi je suis je suis pas du tout
tyrannique. Je suis pas toutique mais
euh les c'est cette disparition de
l'autorité, elle est terrible. À
l'inverse, par contre
dans les entreprises, comme je disais
tout à l'heure, dans les organisations,
là il y a un besoin de démocratie qui
est énorme. C'est-à-dire que les gens
crèvent dans leur boulot. Souvent ils
ont des solutions au problème et parce
qu'ils sont pas à la bonne place dans la
hiérarchie, on les écoute pas.
L'autorité, on vous la donne ou vous la
prenez ?
Et ben en fait ce qui est marrant c'est
que quand j'ai commencé à enseigner,
j'étais dans le côté cool. On est à la
fac, on est entre adultes. En plus quand
vous commencez à enseigner à la fac,
vous avez quasiment l'âge des étudiants.
Donc il y a un truc un peu bizarre qui
est assez sympa aussi. Bon et en fait au
cours des années, j'ai je suis devenu de
plus en plus dur parce que j'ai vu de la
lassitude.
Non non mais parce que j'ai vu que
en fait c'est c'est c'est brutal ce que
je vais dire mais que en fait quand vous
êtes un gros bourin comme moi qui bosse
comme un taré depuis toujours, ben en
fait vous sans sans y réfléchir vous
pensez que tout le monde est comme vous.
Et donc quand je leur donnais un texte à
lire, je me disais bah ils vont se
rendre compte que c'est génial, je leur
apporte le texte. En plus, je fais
toujours très attention que mes
documents soient beaux, c'est-à-dire que
ce soit pas des photocopies de
photocopies, de photocopies et cetera.
Et je me dis pour eux c'est cool quoi.
Je leur ramène leur truc, je lis des
dizaines de bouquins chaque année, je
leur amène le meilleur du meilleur, ils
vont ils vont se délecter quoi. Puis tu
reviens la semaine prochaine, il y en a
pas la moitié qu'on ouvert le truc. Et
là, tu as envie de leur dire "Mais vous
êtes trop cons les amis." Surtout qu'à
la fac en plus les semestres sont très
courts. On a en fait en vrai 10 semaines
de cours, c'est rien du tout. Donc
chaque séance c'est hyper important. Et
donc à force de se rendre compte qu'il
faisait pas le boulot et ben j'ai
commencé à passer dans les rangs la
semaine d'après pour leur dire bah ouais
qu'est-ce que individuellement qu'est-ce
que tu as fait ? qu'est-ce que tu as pas
fait à ramasser les copies et tout mais
à la fac, on n parle jamais de ça entre
nous parce qu'à la fac, la pédagogie
c'est un gros mot parce qu'on est tous
des chercheurs. Et c'est pour ça que
j'aime bien dire que je suis prof, que
je suis enseignant. Regardez tous les
gens que vous vous avez discuté et
cetera, ils disent tous je suis
enseignant chercheur. C'est hyper
important pour dire c'est des
chercheurs. Bon, on s'en fout mon ami.
Mais le prof de lycée qui lit le monde,
c'est c'est un chercheur comme toi.
Tous les jours,
c'est un chercheur tous les jours. Et le
bon journaliste, c'est un chercheur.
Ouais. Ouais. le bon journaliste. Euh
questionnet : doit-on planifier la
décroissance ou continuer à se friser la
moustache et attendre la chute brutale
entre parenthèses
jusqu'ici tout va bien ? H
ouais, c'est la question parfaite. Euh
moi, c'est que j'ai pas de moustache. On
peut pas me friser la moustache. Mais
non mais bien sûr, c'est ce que je dis
moi depuis des années, mais comme tous
les gens lucides qui sont je pense
vraiment nombreux. Encore une fois, la
décroiss là là ils le disent he encore
une fois ils disent depuis dans ce petit
bouquin, ils disent depuis 1990
il y a très longtemps, il y a 30 ans,
depuis 1990, ils le disent nous sommes
rentrés avec certitude dans la
décroissance et qu'en fait la croissance
économique c'est quelque chose du passé
hein. Et il y a par exemple, il y a des
habitants dans le Pacifique hein ou leur
île du Pacifique où il y avait toute
leur histoire familiale depuis toujours.
Et ben cette île maintenant, elle est
sous les eaux. C'est fini pour eux. La
ville de Paradise, voyez ça, c'est
génial. C'est vraiment un truc pour les
psy ça. La ville de Paradise en
Californie, le paradis, elle a brûlé
cette ville.
On a brûlé le paradis. On a on avait
notre paradis terrestre quand vous
regardez la beauté de la France, la
beauté des régions. Mais c'est
incroyable. Moi, j'y suis de plus en
plus sensible. Vous bz en Bretagne, vous
badz dans plein d'endroit, c'est d'une
beauté incroyable. Et on est tous en
train de détruire cet endroit avec nos
bagnoles, nos voyages en avion, notre
viande, nos téléphones portables. C'est
d'une bêtise.
Vous êtes végétarien ?
C'est une bétissant. Non non, je suis
pas végétarien. Non. Et
une bagnole ?
Ouais, j'ai une bagnole. J'adore me
balader dans les usines le weekend et je
prends l'avion viande bien sûr. Ou
ouais. Et justement là où je pense être
cohérent, c'est que mais c'est ça la
politique quand on lit Rousseau. Quand
on lit Rousseau, qu'est-ce qu'il nous
dit ? Il nous dit "Quand je vote, je
dois voter en citoyen." He c'est
l'intérêt général.
C'était quoi le le proverbe que vous
m'aviez dit en début d'émission ? C'est
euh
je
Moi, je j'en ai un pour vous, c'est
comme les investisseurs. Moi moi je
mange ce que je prêche.
Ah oui oui. Walk talk. Ouais, tout à
fait. Ouais. Ouais.
D'accord.
Ouais. Ouais. C'est ça. Le truc des
économistes. Oui, c'est ça. Ça c'est pas
le c'est le truc des traders. C'est que
quand vous donnez un conseil
Ouais. Moi, je préfère recevoir un
conseil d'un trader qui mange son
conseil.
Oui. Oui.
Donc, vous êtes pas végétarien, vous
avez une bagnole, vous prenez l'avion.
C'est ça.
Ouais, tout à fait.
Vous êtes prof à la fac.
Voilà, c'est ça.
Et donc,
tout va bien. Mais en fait, il y en a
beaucoup des comme vous, non ?
Ouais, bien sûr. Mais je pense que c'est
parce que c'est cool. C'est cool. C'est
c'est des c'est des bons slogans, ça
claque.
Non, non, non, c'est pas cool parce que
j'ai jamais déjà c'est pas cool parce
que je le vis mal. C'est que quand je me
balade, et c'est ça que je me dis, c'est
prodigieux. C'est quand je me balade euh
le weekend euh dans les Yvelines, dans
ma bagnole, je culpabilise parce que je
suis en train de ruiner l'avenir de ma
gamine. Je me dis c'est génial c'est que
un plaisir aussi simple de faire 10 km
de bagnole, la situation est tellement
dégradée que je culpabilise. C'est c'est
grandiose quoi. D'arriver à se ruiner la
vie à ce point-là, c'est juste magique
quoi. Mais pour le coup, j'ai jamais
menti là-dessus. C'est j'ai jamais
essayé d'être ce que je suis pas. Et je
pense que la politique c'est ça. La
politique c'est exactement comme
l'éducation, c'est d'avoir des gens
responsables, des gens qui assument mais
pas au sens d'en marche mais au sens où
les mots ont un sens. En avait avant qui
est de nous faire prendre des décisions
qu'on n pas envie de prendre. Je veux
dire, personne n'a envie de prendre des
de payer des impôts, mais si vous
réfléchissez, vous voyez que c'est super
les impôts. Euh par exemple, je sais pas
le fait que les drogues dures soient
interdites, je pense c'est une très
bonne idée. C'est du paternalisme. Même
la sécurité sociale, j'ai essayé d'en
parler tout à l'heure, la sécurité
sociale, c'est totalement paternaliste.
Quand vous regardez votre fiche de paye,
vous avez quasiment
Je peux vous lire un un commentaire là
tout de suite. Fausse gauche bobo molle
du cul et aux poches pleines.
Oui oui écoutez si ça lui fait plaisir
ça pose aucun problème. Je continue sur
la sécurité sociale. Quand vous prenez
votre fiche de pay sommes délirantes qui
vous sont prises tous les mois qui vous
sont prises parce que les cotisations
sociales c'est pas l'entreprise qui les
pay qui les payez. D'accord.
L'entreprise, elle en baille un peu
quand même parce que un salaire qui a
2500 balles, ça fait 5500 balles, non ?
Et ben ça c'est une erreur. C'est ce
qu'on appelle la théorie de l'incidence
fiscale. La théorie de l'incidence
fiscale. Ben
tout le monde dit ça.
Non. Non mais oui, tout le monde dit ça,
mais c'est empiriquement très faux.
C'est-à-dire que ce n'est pas la
personne qui fait le chèque aux impôts
qui paye l'impôt. Je vous le redis très
sérieusement, les cotisations sociales,
elles sont prises sur le salaire. Et on
le voit très nettement dans les travaux
des économistes, c'est qu'à chaque fois
que vous avez une augmentation du taux
de cotisation sociale, par exemple, pour
financer les retraites, et ben derrière
les salaires n'augmentent pas parce que
les boîtes se récupèrent. C'est-à-dire
que évidemment vous avez raison que
l'échec à l'URSAF, c'est fait par la
boîte, mais en fait la richesse est crée
par le travailleur. Un petit coucou à
Carl Marx au passage. Et évidemment
évidemment que la totalité des
cotisations sociales sont réglées par
les salariés. C'est une évidence
évidente, mais ça aussi si on la prenait
à l'école, ça serait mieux. Bref, on
vous prend des sommes énormes tous les
mois sans vous demander votre avis.
C'est totalement paternaliste. Mais
c'est génial parce qu'après quand vous
allez avoir des gosses, bim, vous
touchez de la tune. Vous êtes malade,
bim, vous touchez de la tune. Vous êtes
vieux, bim, vous touchez de la tune.
C'est fabuleux. Mais si je vous donnais
l'argent tous les mois, vous auriez
incapable d'épargner toute cette
somme-là. Donc la sécurité sociale,
c'est un truc comme on dirait
aujourd'hui de vieux hommes blancs dont
beaucoup d'eau droite. Regardez la
création de la sécurité sociale.
Évidemment, ça a d'abord été porté par
la gauche. Mais dans le conseil aussi
hein,
pardon,
il y avait des femmes.
Ouais, il y avait quelques femmes. Dans
le Conseil national de la résistance,
dans le conseil national de la
résistance, vous avez des vieux câau.
Des vieux câaux qu'on appellerait
aujourd'hui à juste titre, sans doute
assez raciste, misogynes et cetera. Et
donc ça, j'aimerais bien qu'on s'arrête
là-dessus. Vous avez un pays en ruine.
En ruine. En plus, vous avez le baby
boom. Très bizarre. Au lycée, on nous
dit toujours le baby boom, c'est génial.
Ah bon ? C'est génial d'avoir trois ou
quatre cinq gosses par femme dans un
pays en ruine. Pourquoi c'est génial ?
Comment ils font les gens ? C'est
l'enfer. Donc vous avez la charge de ça,
vous avez plein d'hommes qui sont
blessés, vous avez plein d'hommes qui
sont prisonniers. Et là, vous avez le
patronat alors évidemment qui a été
totalement discrédité par la
collaboration, ce qui explique le truc.
Vous avez le prestige de l'Union
soviétique, ce qui explique le truc.
Vous avez le Parti communiste qui est le
premier parti de France, ce qui explique
le truc. N'empêche que vous avez ce
moment, vous avez un pays qui est
complètement ruiné et là vous avez des
gens qui se réunissent en disant "Vous
savez quoi ? Maintenant, quand vous
allez être malade, vous allez toucher de
l'argent. Quand vous allez être vieux,
vous allez touché de l'argent. Quand
vous êtes au chômage, vous avez touché
de l'argent. C'est hallucinant.
Ou ben à l'époque, il y avait la
capacité d'avoir du pétrole pas cher que
Non,
non. Je pense que c'est un contexte
politique totalement unique et c'est
prodigieux de se dire essayez
d'imaginer, je le dis tout le temps mes
étudiants, essayez d'imaginer
aujourd'hui qu'en France que la SQ
n'existe pas, d'accord ? Que tout est
privé et imaginez dans un pays qui est
je sais pas qui est 10 fois plus riche
qu'à l'époque, même avec le Covid, même
avec le Covid, dans le pays qui est 10
fois plus riche qu'à l'époque, imaginez
là, vous avez un candidat ou une
candidate en 2022 qui nous dit "Bah, je
vais créer un truc s'appelle la SQ et
vous serez payé quand vous êtes malade
et cetera." et tout le monde dirait mais
vous êtes fou la mondialisation c'est
impossible vous avez coulé toutes les
boîtes et ben il y a des gens qui ont
réussi à créer ça et justement dans les
rare moment où je vais mal puisque vous
avez compris ça arrive je pense à ça et
là quand j'aurai plus de temps, j'ai
vraiment envie juste de lire la presse
de l'époque de me replonger dans le
contexte de l'époque et de me dire on a
réussi ils ont réussi à créer un truc
aussi fabuleux et c'est pour ça que je
vous dis que c'est important la
distinction entre l'État et la sécurité
sociale parce que la sécurité sociale
c'est un prodige du point de vue
économique. notamment les retraites. Il
y a beaucoup de gens qui ne savent pas
comment fonctionne le système de
retraite. Encore une fois, le système de
retraite, si on nous prend de l'argent
tous les mois qui est versé tous les
mois, ça ne coûte rien. C'est le
meilleur placement de votre vie et
justement, on vous demande pas de votre
avis et c'est juste fabuleux. Et ça, que
ça soit pas enseigné à tous les jeunes
français, c'est incroyable.
Question internet, mais rappelez-vous la
prochaine fois que vous avez un peu mal,
la solitude est un cadeau des dieux.
OK, pas mal. J'y penserais.
Question internet. Selon lui, quel
modèle de société ayant existé serait un
exemple à suivre ?
Mais moi, je crois pas, j'ai pas de de
réponse évidente. J'ai l'impression que
c'est la réponse que fait tout le monde
que dans les années 60, les gens étaient
quand même plus heureux que maintenant.
Mais j'en sais rien si c'est vrai. Mais
encore une fois euh je pense que si on
arrête de se farcir la tête avec plein
de conneries comme malheureusement je le
fais comme plein de gens toute la
journée, encore une fois, il faut juste
se rappeler qu'on vit et pardon même
avec la crise du Covid dans un pays qui
est immensément riche. Et d'ailleurs, on
le sait tous parce que pour les les
méchants comme moi qui prennent l'avion
une fois par an, quand on revient d'un
pays étranger, qu'est-ce que disent les
gens ? Ah qu'est-ce qu'on est bien en
France. Qu'est-ce qu'on est bien en
France.
Surtout les mecs qui vivent euh dans la
dans la ceinture Persique, ils aiment
bien dire ça mais ils aiment pas payer
les impôts là. Et donc euh en fait ne je
pense que malheureusement une des plus
grandes victoires des économistes qui
sont donc euh qui s'appellent libéraux
alors qu'ils ne le sont pas du tout qui
sont conservateurs, une de leurs plus
grandes victoires, c'est d'avoir réussi
à nous faire croire qu'on est pauvre.
Quand vous regardez l'actualité
économique, même hors Covid, on vous
parle que du déficit, on vous parle que
de la dette. On vous fait comprendre en
permanence que vous êtes dans un pays
pauvre, un pays qui peut rien faire.
Mais c'est totalement faux. Regardez les
bagnoles sur l'autoroute. Regardez les
bagnoles sur l'autoroute. Tout le nombre
de gens qui roulent dans des bagnoles à
40000 ou 50000 €. Regardez les
incroyables maisons qu'il y a partout en
France. Il y a une richesse colossale
dans ce pays.
Des bagnoles à 50000 € on en voit de
moins en moins souvent.
Ah bah moi j'ai l'impression d'en voir
quand même beaucoup. Bref, par contre,
on voit on voit souvent des autoroutes
avec des sacrés trous dedans. Non, vous
avez pas vu ça vous quand vousz vous
balader un petit peu ?
Non, mais je pense qu'il y a une
hypocrisie qui est totalement
compréhensible et que malheureusement la
crise aggrave,
c'est que les gens, pardon, je suis
juste, il y a plein de gens, enfin, ils
sont pas si nombreux que ça, mais quand
même qui ont beaucoup de tunes et juste
ils ont pas envie de partager et je
comprends qu'ils aient pas envie de
partager mais la solution c'est le
partage des amis.
Question internet. Comment reprendre le
contrôle de nos fonds avec lesquels
l'état fait n'importe quoi ?
Nos fonds, quel fond ?
Mais j'ai pas compris
que par exemple on paye des impôts tous
les mois et que quand vous prenez
l'autoroute à 6 en sortant de Paris, il
y a des trous
il y a des trous, c'est même plus des
nids de poule, c'est c'est des nids
d'ruche. Vous êtes motard, vous passez
là-dedans. C'est c'est un c'est c'est
scandaleux. On a l'impression de se
retrouver au fin fond du cul de la
Biélorussie, de la Serbie euh avec un si
on mettait des vaches.
C'est vrai que la 6 au départ de Paris,
elle est assez sympa. Quand je la prends
quand je la prends avec mon vélo, c'est
vrai que ça fait ça fait mal aux fesses.
Euh
vous allez vous d'aller vite, hein.
C'est 110 quand même. Ouais, ouais, mais
je sais, je freine le là. Effectivement,
on touche à un gros problème qui est
bien connu, c'est la faiblesse du
parlement. C'est-à-dire que j'ai fait
j'ai Non, non, mais bon, non, mais c'est
juste évident. Euh là encore quand
regardez bless ça sur quel point
intellectuel ou le le renoncement du
parlement ?
Ouais. Je sais pas un peu tout mais euh
bon ça commence un tout petit peu à
changer mais quand vous regardez par ex
aux États-Unis quand il y a des
commissions parlementaires, vous êtes
convoqués devant une commission
parlementaire, vous paniquez comme un
malade parce que vous savez que si vous
dites un truc qui est pas vrai, vous
allez en prison. D'accord ? Donc les
gens, ils sont un tout petit peu obligés
de dire la vérité. duurberg, il a pas
aimé du tout d'ailleurs.
Voilà, il y a des moyens d'enquête qui
sont considérables suite à la grande
crise financière de 2008. Il y a une
fantastique commission parlementaire qui
a été mise en place aux États-Unis. On a
les noms, on sait ce qu'on fait les mecs
et tout ça.
Qui qui a été en prison d'ailleurs ?
Alors voilà, le problème exactement
c'est qu'il y a eu le petit souci,
personne n'est allé en prison alors que
ça aurait dû être le cas. Mais en
France, par exemple, ce qu'il faut
savoir, j'ai fait un petit travail avec
une collègue, euh il y a des aides très
importantes aux entreprises, euh plein
d'aides à tous les niveaux, au niveau
national, au niveau régional. Euh et en
fait on n' même pas la liste de toutes
ces aides. Personne ne la connaît. Il y
a aucune étude quasiment en France sur
quasiment aucun sujet sur effectivement
euh la dépense publique, sur les
différentes politiques qui sont menées.
Il y a aucune évaluation qui est faite.
Euh j'en parle avec mon père déjà il y a
30 ans. On parle en permanence de
l'évaluation des politiques publiques.
Ce qui est le B àabas. Vous avez tout à
fait raison. Et ce qui est fondamental
pour le fonctionnement de la démocratie,
que les gens sachent à quoi servent leur
impôts, cette information, elle n'existe
pas. C'est-à-dire que personne n'est
foutu de savoir dans plein de trucs où
va l'argent, qui touche l'argent,
qu'est-ce qu'ils en font, est-ce que les
objectifs poursuivis par la politique
sont atteints. Ça n' Et là, voyez,
justement, dès que vous commencez à
parler de ça, à un journaliste des
grands médias, le mec il s'endort au
bout de 30 secondes. Ça n'intéresse
personne. Ça n'intéresse personne.
Ça intéresse beaucoup de monde.
Non, mais oui, tout à fait. Question
question d'internet. Euh euh quel serait
l'impact d'une réduction de la natalité
selon lui ?
Alors, je dirais qu'il y aurait moins
d'enfants.
Vous êtes économiste ? Non.
Ouais, ouais. Je suis économiste assez
brillant. Euh bah, c'est vrai que par
exemple, quand je discute avec des gens
plus jeunes, ça m'impressionne le nombre
de filles en particulier euh qui
décident de pas avoir d'enfant pour la
question écologique. Je trouve que ça
c'est quand même d'une tristesse
incroyable. C'est que je connais
plusieurs personnes femmes d'une
trentaine d'années euh alors qu'on qu'on
souhaite ne pas avoir d'enfants,
évidemment, ça me pose vraiment aucun
problème. Mais qu'on fasse ça pour des
raisons écologiques, je trouve ça quand
même d'une tristesse assez incroyable et
je pense que c'est c'est important d'en
parler. C'est qu'on voit bien que là
l'effondrement écologique touche à ce
qu'il y a plus intime d'entre nous comme
le fait d'avoir des enfants. Je trouve
ça vraiment incroyable.
On va arriver à la fin de notre
interview. Il y a il y a des questions
mais des questions a plein plein plein
mais on va pas avoir le temps de toutes
les prendre.
Euh
est-ce que vous êtes triste ou est-ce
que vous êtes lucide ?
Ah ben je je suis hyper triste parce que
je suis lucide.
Heureux les simples les simples d'esprit
aujourd'hui j'ai compris.
Non mais je franchement moi si vous
voulez la question du bonheur m'a jamais
m'a jamais intéressé quoi. Je ça m'a
jamais intéressé d'être un peu
autiste.
Pardon ?
Vous êtes pas un peu autiste ? Asperger
? Non, vous êtes pas Asperger.
Non, j'en sais rien mais bon.
Vous avez des livres à conseiller à
notre communauté ?
Grave. Ah, j'ai plein de bouquins à
conseiller.
Alors, trois
euh J'enaderai adieu à la croissance.
Euh, Richard Wilkinson et Kate Picket.
Euh et le titre m'échappe mais le
dernier bouquin qu'ils ont sorti qui
doit être pour vivre heureux, vivons
égaux, un truc comme ça, aux éditions
Les liens qui libèrent.
Et euh
Gill Rau, la dispute des économistes. Ça
c'est interdit ça. Ah
non, un troisème vraiment bien.
Bah j'ai déjà
le trè il était pas bien le dernier.
Non, c'est ça. Non, mais j'ai déjà parlé
du Sucman du Stiglitz. Qu'est-ce que
j'ai lu vraiment de bien bien ? Bah, je
sais pas, ça me revient pas. Bref,
Papin et Pipou font président et premier
ministre. Vous le connaissez pas
celui-là ? Ça va bientôt sortir.
Ah si, Talon, l'archipel des sans arons.
Très très bon bouquin d'économie. Achil
Talon, l'archipel des sans arons.
Est-ce que vous avez un conseil pour les
jeunes générations ?
Euh oui oui. Acheter du terrain. Je dis
ça très sérieusement. Pourquoi acheter
du terrain ?
Et bah pour pouvoir avoir de quoi
bouffer.
Alors
ça c'est très marrant
parce que je je discutais avec un un
banquier de classe mondiale.
Hm.
genre
costaud costaud h
il disait surtout pas de faire ça parce
que euh comme l'État va se retrouver
dans une merde noire, il va taxer en
priorité les biens qui ne sont pas
liquides.
Ah ouais.
C'est-à-dire les terrains et
l'immobilier. Hm
hm. Oui, mais moi moi ou voyez c'est
marrant parce que vous me ramenez
question de monétaire. Moi, je vous
ramène un truc très euh Non, je suis
très sérieux. Enfin, je veux dire encore
une fois la la pression sur les
ressources, vous allez voir dans les
années décennies qui viennent, c'est
c'est certain. Donc, je pense qu'avoir
une terre fertile aujourd'hui, c'est
c'est très sérieusement le meilleur
investissement que quiconque puisse
faire vraiment pour avoir de quoi
bouffer accès à l'eau potable.
Alors, si vous achetez si vous achetez
le terrain, il faut acheter la poudre
qui va avec.
à poudre bah
pour protéger votre terrain
comme un luucque
c'est ça ?
Oui oui ça peut venir. Ouais ça peut
venir
en mode Mad Max.
Un autre conseil pour les jeunes
générations.
Euh bah la sophrologie, je trouve la
sophrologie c'est pas mal. Apprendre à
respirer
avec le Covid.
Ouais c'est avec le Covid c'est d'autant
plus nécessaire. Donc mais non
sérieusement je pense que c'est il faut
vraiment lire. Il y a plein de sources
d'information et je suis surpris
moi-même de voir à quel point et je dis
pas ça parce que j'en écrit, c'est
l'inverse, j'en écris parce que j'ai
constaté ça, les livres sont
irremplaçables. Il y a une qualité, il y
a un rythme dans les livres qui est
absolument irremplaçable. Donc si vous
voulez euh grandir dans tous les sens du
terme, vous vous déconnectez et vous
posez avec un bouquin. En plus
maintenant, il y a plein de bouquins
qu'on trouve d'occasion à des prix
dérisoires, des des classiques de de ce
que vous voulez. Posez-vous avec des
livres. Je pense vraiment que le salut
viendra par le livre, le livre des
livres. Enfin, je peux en faire plein
comme ça.
Une question, une dernière,
une question d'hier de pseudo qui
s'appelle hier. Une question pour
aujourd'hui. Jolie. Ouais.
Ouais, pas mal.
Ouais.
Le système, il est mort.
Bah le
oui, enfin c'est sûr que le on voit bien
qu'il y avait une cohérence des
institutions qui ont été mise en place à
partir de 1945 surtout en France centré
sur l'État les grands problèmes qui ont
les grands problèmes les grands
programmes qui ont fonctionné le
nucléaire le TGV même Concorde et cetera
et puis effectivement depuis les années
72 70 on [__] en France on n arrive
plus
crise du pétrole
crise du pétrole exactement maintenant
effectivement la question écologique
Oui. Oui.
Je sais pas exactement ce que ça veut
dire le système mais en tout cas c'est
sûr que toute notre imaginaire bah lisez
Bernard Maris quoi. Lisez Bernard Maris
lisez Bernard Maris vraiment. Et
effectivement il avait tout compris sur
la les limites de la mondialisation sur
les limites de l'écologie. Lisez son
petit bouquin souriez vous êtes français
qui est absolument magique qui est hyper
facile à lire. Et pour les gens de
gauche, son plus beau bouquin c'est Ah
merde lettre [__] comment ça s'appelle
? être ah au socialiste, je sais pas
quoi. Oui, il raconte justement sa
propre histoire, son père qui était
instituteur,
il il a lu Jor Proudon et cetera. Et
donc il y a un bouquin qui s'appelle al
mais je c'est dingue lettre
lettre socialiste ou je sais pas quoi
chez Albert Michel et c'est un bouquin
absolument magique, hyper émouvant et je
pense que là vraiment c'est le bouquin à
en ce moment.
Vous pensez quoi des cryptos ?
Ça alors ça bon je fais sans doute une
erreur mais ça m'intéresse pas du tout.
J'arrive pas je
enfin tout le monde le sait quoi. Le
Bitcoin par exemple la dépense
énergétique et lié au Bitcoin. Enfin
j'explique pas les c'est c'est trop long
ouverte au grou de l'économie qui nous
Non non non non.
Il y a socialistes dans le titre.
Il prennent pour des imbéciles.
Oui. Bon celui-là celui-là il est bien
aussi mais il est daté maintenant. Non
non c'est il y a juste socialiste. Enfin
bon
les cryptos c'est fou.
Ouais. Donc je vous dis les cryptos,
j'arrive pas à m'y intéresser. Euh juste
voilà, la dépense énergétique euh pour
produire du Bitcoin, elle est supérieure
à la dépense énergétique de de certains
pays entiers. C'est absolument
incroyable.
Gillot, merci.
Merci à vous.
[Musique]